We're not close.
That's why I'm annoyed with these people on the internet because
the audience thinks we're close. They play it like we're close.
I'm sorry. You don't even know me. Maybe you guys are close to
each other, but y'all aren't close to me and you keep dragging
me into your beef for them or Destiny when they lie and cheat
on each other. Kelly Jean especially. This is She's a pathological
>> What the Britney? >> She get she getting hit.
No. No. No. That's Abba. That's Abba. That's Abba. That's Abba.
Just be clear. That's Aba. >> Aba said that. Why?
>> I think she got to basically the point where she was
like, "Ah, it's really tragic that he has a son."
And I thought it was pretty up at the time. Um, I still think
that's up when the the son is there and he exists and you say
that about him. I think that's reallyed up. >> I want unapologetic
anti- genocide propalinian perspectives. >> Oh, is he calling
Molina a pathological liar, too? Yum.
I guess I think this is like broadly about Man, I don't even
know broadly what it's about. Maybe I should uh read a little
earlier. She seems quite upset with Contra Points. I don't know
how that led to her like leaking DMs with former DG orbiters,
but
or maybe she asked, hold on, I say leaking. She possibly asked
to to show the DMs. I shouldn't just say leaking. I don't know
that she but she shows DMs with ABBA about her exit from that
space. Will you admit you were wrong about aristocracy in the
Canadian programs? the Toronto programs actually happened. No,
I will not. No, I will not. I think I'm 100% correct on that.
And I think that is 100% indicative of how she's talked about
the subject for a long time and how she's broadly like not very
um not very reliable. You see how that works though? We have
examples of her being like a extremely hyperbolic narrator and
we can point to them because we're not we don't just say you're
an extremely hyperbolic or unreliable narrator with no evidence.
It's awesome. Someone made a great addendum. No, they didn't.
Only mute. No, they didn't. Anyway, we continue. I >> know
she's doing that, you know, nerd divergent thing where it's like
a desire to be very like quote nuanced, but you're actually just
being bigoted. Get over it, girl. Move on. And I know >> Britney
Britney is who that post was made about, by the way. Like, Britney
Britney is the person quite literally who Contra Points is venting
about. That's very funny. That's That's just very funny. Like,
she's the exact thing that Contra Points is venting about. I
feel like Contra Points and Hassan could have a conversation
on this topic. I don't know if if Contra Points and Britney could
we'll say >> it's hard because I struggle with wanting
to be like um but actually facts and then you lose yourself in
the sauce, right? So, I'm deeply compassionate. Okay, here's
an example of how I usually end contacted friendships with people
online. Now, I've tried to do it two ways. I've tried to just
unfriend people, but that never works. I've tried to write them
messages, and sometimes people get mad and post it on Twitter,
and usually people agree like Britney was pretty cordial. I don't
know what you're mad about. Here's an example. So, during the
Destiny arc, okay, >> so if you're if you guys aren't aware,
I had a Destiny arc. >> I'll show you the beginning of
the arc and how it happened. And then >> didn't we all?
Didn't we all? Didn't we all? Evil Johnny Bravo thing for the
19 months. Let's go. >> I'll explain kind of a little bit
of why this co like relates to everything happening, right? Chess
says she is pro Palestine, but not how you want. I want unapologetic,
anti- genocide, pro Palestinian perspectives. I am not interested
in like in any way
watering down the genocide that is happening. If you need to
water down the genocide that is happening, it's not good enough
and it's deeply cruel and >> I just I just accidentally
deleted somebody's message in uh in Twitch chat and I didn't
mean to. Sorry, I was hovering over. I didn't mean to. I just
repasted it. Joe Palestinians lives were saved is a stupid point.
bringing attention to Israel committing war crimes and its conduct
most likely contributed to people donating more to various Palestinian
Sure. I think what they're saying is
that actually is a good point. Yeah, I'm sure I'm sure like probably
bring light to war crimes is a thing. I don't know if all of
those dead kids were all war crimes, which sounds up to say.
Space goes, thank you for the six months. Thank you. Thank you.
I don't know. Like I understand that sounds up to say, but like
that can be collateral damage from actual like strikes that were,
you know, vetted and and done, right? Probably not every time
though. Probably not every time. A lot of dead kids.
See, it's hard to it's hard to talk through this stuff. I especially
I would need to see each of the um additional things. The the
problem is when once you aggregate things, you see like Gaza
completely leveled, just totally destroyed, right? and broadly
no sanctions against Israel where the the like I think it was
like a month and a half, two months ago we first we got our first
sanctions against Israel at all. Right. They just did whatever
they wanted for as long as they wanted and got real bad. Anyway,
should people stop talking about trans and gay rights since Trump
won on being anti-trans and anti-gay? Uh wait, people should
absolutely try to stick to reality on trans issues, right? like
people actually detached from reality on trans issues and that
was used against Democrats because Democrats supported it four
years ago. By the way, they didn't even support it this election.
They weren't outwardly like saying, "Oh, no, bigot, shut up."
No. Um, like girls, girls in the NCAA should be able to compete
even if they're, you know, uh, male to female transitioners,
right? They're trans people. They should be able to compete.
It's dude, but there was none of that this election. It was still
used as a cudel against them. So, yeah, you have to stick you
have to stick to reality. Yes, you do. The issue is with the
the trans stuff, you can get probably a slightly better idea
of reality. With the with the Israel stuff, you really don't
know everything that's going on there. You don't know cuz the
clips are already like what do I just trust that this clips even
from Gaza or like there's a lot of there's a lot of other things.
>> I just want to point out you do what you're worried
I will do. I have never spoken this much after getting one guy
by Chad. >> Ooh. Ooh. Ooh. Ooh. Ooh. I called Willie out
for his total inability to read and his his response is, "She's
not going to you, bro. You don't have to defend it. You can't
read. You dumb. You dumb as Willie." Anyway, uh I already posted
a more substantial thing showing exactly why he's incapable of
reading and why it's like stupid that they included those pictures
at all. All right.
He's totally He's totally right. But we'll get into it later.
We'll discuss more of how he's Anyway,
Willy's uh Willy's done. I think Willy's done and not just on
Twitch. Okay,
we've um we've identified him as somebody who's not intelligent
enough to be here and we're going to continue to identify him
as somebody who's not intelligent enough to be here and >> deeply
wrong.
Okay. So, if Natalie continues to both sides this issue, it's
going to be wrong. It's okay to show the nuance. It's okay to
be deep about it. I certainly have been accused of both siding
it, but that's why I changed my rhetoric because at the end of
the day, we can wait to have other convers. >> I still
support Willie. He kicked Hassan's ass in that debate. Really?
I've never watched that content, so it's hard for me to say,
but I've heard people who actually have brain cells who've watched
that content and they say that it's not like that, but
I I don't know. I can't comment. All I can say is broadly over
this issue and over a couple past issues, lay seems totally
We'll see. We'll see how right now we need to be focused on the
genocide. >> Okay? We need to make sure we're focusing
on the genocide. And by the way, you think she's pro genocide?
Wait until I read you what she wrote on Reddit. Okay, >> so
when the Destiny thing happened, let me pull it up. Hold on.
I've got a whole thing here. Okay, hold on, guys. Let me pull
this up. 149 today. >> Okay, one. All these videos are
privated now cuz I don't want people thinking I stand by associating
with Destiny. I didn't know he was as bad as he was when I first
got in contact with him. Obviously. Obviously. I didn't know
that. I didn't know. And I actually Why is she doing a fake British
accent now? This is atrocious. >> I don't know. Maddy's
You're welcome to hop on the stream if you want to explain why
Willy Mack isn't a low IQ loser. >> I want totally welcome
to hop on. You're totally hop on. My criticism here is incredibly
wellounded. >> I'm so sorry. >> He can't read. He
can't read. He can't read. He can't read >> off even before
the really >> He literally has to rightclick every line
of every tweet he tries to go to and write. He has to rightclick
it and put it into an extension. and copy paste it into a TTS
thing because he cannot >> The bad allegations came out.
So that tells you something. Here's a video we first did together.
This is our first time talking, our first time collabing. Okay.
I ask him or I tell him about friendships. Same with Ethan and
everyone else. It's no fun, right? And so when I when I talk
to people like you, that's the opportunity, right? And like my
audience is >> Oh, and PS, I should tell you, I was so
annoyed at the whole group dynamics with the bread tube people
that I was like, "Okay, I'm going to stop collabing with YouTubers
cuz like I don't understand the social dynamics." And I took
a break for a long time. And then when I finally felt confident
again, I was like, "Hey audience, who should I collab with?"
And somebody in my audience was like, "Can you talk to Destiny?
Progressive, non-binary, fights fights uh Republicans." And I
was like, "Okay,
I mean,
Chad says, "Do you have a date for this?" This is uh January
28th, 2022. Okay. January 28, 2022. This is our conversation
together. Okay. This is the opportunity. But
they don't know me that 100%. Though, I do have a theory that
you can't ever be authentic except by yourself because I'm too
hyper aware of people's like their space, like them in my space
that I think my most authentic self is when I'm completely alone.
This is prior to meeting my uh now partner. And I just need you
to know I agree with this. That's why I say when I'm with my
partner, I feel like I'm completely alone cuz I'm completely
>> unmasked and authentic.
>> I stand by what I said here. >> But that's why
my marriage is so special to me because it's the first time in
my life I've been in a room with somebody else and been completely
myself,
>> which is >> Britney is a low cow. Everything she
says is No, not everything she says. She uh she is like kind
of um sometimes, but she I know a lot of people who
get a lot out of listening to Britney. Um she's got like some
takes on things that people like. Maybe that's all like bad takes.
Maybe it's like bad for people or something. I don't know. But
I've heard people describe why they like Britney. And it's like
I I get it. I get it. >> It's interesting. So when you're
hearing this and you're you're like thinking about it, don't
How do I say this? I think I'm taking issue with the fact that
like you gave Biden an A minus because I'm Oh, wait. Wrong clip.
Damn it. This is the wrong clip. Okay, first of all, I did take
issue with the fact that he gave Biden an A minus. And that's
when I realized he wasn't progressive. Okay, but hold on. That
was the wrong clip. I I Oops. Oops. >> Why does she always
feel the need to say her marriage is great unprompted? This is
something that sets me off as well, BB Poison. When somebody
when I'm not when I'm talking about something else and somebody
stands up like the Manurian Canada goes, "My marriage is fantastic.
My marriage is great. I'm like, uh, you sure about that? Are
what? You good? I didn't ask. I didn't I wasn't saying otherwise.
Okay. Oh my god. What is >> Wait, I linked my video's wrong.
I'm going to cry. I'm going to cry. This is the wrong clip. But
yes, I actually was going to bring that up later. Destiny is
not a progressive. He's been a liberal through and through, and
I remember being upset with him for giving Biden an A+. Wait,
is this the link, guys? Boomer Britney. Boomer Britney. Hold
on. I'll use the I'll use the n word. Uh you see a lot of normies
on the internet today. Um so yeah, it's definitely not the place
that it was like 10 years ago. Not that that's good or bad, but
it's definitely a way that it's changed. >> Well, I think
the consequences are clear, right? Like a lot of normies are
on the internet. A lot of people's bosses see their stuff. A
lot of people try to curb their talk. Even myself, I see myself.
Actually, this is one thing that I thought was fascinating about
your interaction with Mr. >> Not good start, guys. Not
a good start. She doesn't know her clips. She doesn't have her
clips in order. >> Okay, this is it. There was a time when
he was trying to explain to you that he wanted to game with you
offline and you're like ooh like that's you know and for me I'm
like ooh so I prefer to have conversations offline if I want
to have a real conversation with someone quote unquote not that
we're not having a real conversation now but there's just certain
ways I talk in private that I just don't talk that way on the
internet because I tried to be aware that there's a general audience
that maybe won't understand me you know what I mean but my like
I like to think my Discord's like a >> happy Friday vile
what's up >> safe space for people to say like Okay. So,
right. PS, the Discord is a great safe space. It's actually gotten
even more of a safe space for people to say
what's in their heart's mind, but nothing bigoted people. Nothing
bigoted. Okay. I'm trying to explain to him that I can only have
real connections with people when the cameras aren't there because
otherwise we're working. Okay. So, when Destiny burned the bridge
with me and publicly smeared me and was acting like he blew up
on me, it was like as if your coworker, imagine you're working
with somebody and your coworker is going around being like this,
>> you watch during this time, I think. So, do you know
how Destiny misread his relationship with her so badly? Um, the
impression I got from her relationship with Destiny was she wants
to be like the expert on certain things and Destiny was like
challenging that and she sort of had a blow up about it and she
was sort of like
She was talking about like um trauma from her assault which is
like up and and okay I get it but I think she kind of like she
thought Destiny was invalidating that and she made it clear and
I I think I wasn't like a anybody really to Destiny. This might
have been the first time I DM'd him or one of the first times.
I was like yeah if you keep talking about this topic you won't
be friends anymore, right? like you you don't understand that
this person is like attaching you to their assault and when they
think about that if they have like bad like when they see you
they're going to think about that and when they think about that
they're going to see you like that is like it's not not like
you not she's thinking like you me or something but like literally
there will be an association there and if you continue to reinforce
that association and have this conversation you will never be
friends cuz it's like like you are kind of trying to invalidate
this experience for her by what you're saying to her right like
to her That's how she feels. So, you shouldn't keep trying to
have this conversation. Just like let her be like, you need to
know to back
>> He does really enjoy doing that. Also, I need to say
now it's very important. I really like the white outfit she wears.
It's giving like Kate Bush. I don't like this outfit very much.
It was very important. Thank you. Just like what the shut up.
>> No, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. How do you feel
about Destiny saying her opinions are only based on self-p protection
and cope from her own assault and how you can reverse Uno that
to say how Destiny's stance is that he's totally not broken from
being ah I didn't watch I didn't read to the end before I started
um yeah no I think uh
I think he was basically that's like a really disingenuous way
to have that conversation right when it's like I can see why
both people are invested in having the positions they do but
Destiny goes I'm totally objective with no baggage in having
this position position, right? But he says Britney has baggage
to to be invested and have that position, right? I think that's
really weird to me that I didn't know that. And like he was just
because the discounting was, oh, she's emotional and that's why
this is happening, right? Yeah. I think that's um that that was
weird to me. So, I think there's something there for sure. She
just said Sne's being open-minded that broke Destiny's brain.
I think it was more her talking about him, right? And basically
like the subtle the subtle like subtweeting she was doing. I
think that was what was him off at the time. Trust me, I'm not
going to take Britney's side on a lot of this stuff. I I have
pretty objective opinions, I think, on Britney Simon being like
wrong in that case. And yeah, when she did the interview with
Dr. Honda, that was pretty bad, right? Like that was pretty bad.
But I think I think from the other side, there were two people
who were Aya and Destiny who both had that kind of trauma, both
very invested in saying that kind of trauma doesn't affect me
in any way. And there's just that's a normal thing. That's a
normal thing to think. Right.
And I'm going to say neither side was unbiased in that conversation
is all I'll say. Right. So I think I think she had some like
logically unreasonable takes, but emotionally like I I just said,
"Hey, if I identified this in my friendship, I would try to back
off." Right. Not. But it's always I'll also say this. It's always
way harder when you're in it, right? When you're in that relationship,
it's way harder to know, oh, this is something I have to back.
You don't do the dispassionate like read of people. You have
like all of your own baggage caught up in things. So, I don't
know. Not Not even like a ton of judgment there to be honest.
>> Destiny leaking the herpes thing was also pretty bad.
That was just
>> Uh yeah, he leaked lots of things about her. It was
probably unnecessary.
I thought I thought their going back and forth got really personal
and I don't know. It's I don't know. Yeah. I hit >> Woman
betrayed me and I was like I don't even know you, bro.
Like I don't even know you cuz all the times I talk to Destiny,
it was only him ranting about his relationships and needing advice.
Do you know what I'm saying?
The only time these YouTubers ever talk to me is to talk about
their own lives. And it's because I'm very private with my life.
So even when they say, "How are you? What's going on?" I'd keep
it pretty private because I was waiting to see if we would build
to something more, you know? So when Destiny burned the bridge
with me and I said, "He's calling him a dad, too." No. Yeah.
That's the thing I'm talking about is like it got really personal
and she called him a dad and said I think she got to basically
the point where she was like, "Ah, it's really tragic that he
has a son."
And I thought it was pretty up at the time. Um, I still think
that's up when the the son is there and he exists and you say
that about him. I think that's reallyed up. You might you could
say he's a that's that's whatever to me. Okay. I think it's weird
to
uh I we could rewatch the clips. I don't even want to go back
to it to be honest. >> As time goes on, >> I feel
like that proves to be more true, but he has time to fix it.
Let's see if he does.
>> Sure. Sure.
>> Hope so.
>> Yeah. I think the reason Destiny probably liked talking
to Britney Simon is because she talked to both him and Molina
and
that like he felt like he could get like a sounding board for
his and Molina's relationship. I don't know. I think that's more
why he was friends with Britney Simon like in the long
>> Hey, you need to talk to me offline. And people were
like, he wants to talk to you on stream. You have to talk to
him on stream. And I was like, I don't want to talk to him on
stream. If he's really upset with me, we should talk offline
because I once again assume that people are coming to work and
going home. >> Oh, that would actually be probably that
is a good recommendation. Like if you speak on stream, you have
to maintain all of your positions. You can't back down from anything,
right? And you're you're not going to be able to have like an
empathetic conversation as much. You'll have like a very very
like logical conversation where you have to, you know, you have
to perform for your audience.
So, probably talking on stream never gonna work out >> because
I am at work right now. And guys, when I turn off my stream,
I go home because I touch grass. I have a real life, right? A
real life with a with a a special interest in watching YouTube
videos, but a real life. So, I was trying to say to Destiny,
if you really want to have a healthy friendship, you got to talk
to me offline. But he couldn't do it. And I knew Destiny's pattern.
I knew if I went to him and talked to him online on stream, he
would have used my mental health against me, which he did for
two years. He would have tried to use all those things even though
none of it was true. Even though I was very calm through this
process and he was yelling,
>> See, I don't I don't really This is like a for this
specific thing. I think this is a re-worping. This is like a
warping of events.
I think she had every right to say like, "Oh, I don't want to
have this conversation because you're going to say that this
is the reason, right?" But I think she was actually because of
some past trauma incapable of engaging with this in a way that
was um calm and rational, which is fine and expected and she
shouldn't even be judged for it. But then
like I I don't think it was just Destiny twisting it against
her disingenuously in that one case. >> Everyone painted
it. Even Kyle in the moment said, "Destiny, you're really logical
and Britney's very emotional." Even though if you go back and
watch the content, which I recommend you do, I am incredibly
calm and he's incredibly
>> Yeah, he probably he probably did sound like deranged,
but I don't think that means one of you isn't like impassion
or sorry, one of you isn't biased more than the other. Uh, but
what I will say is like it's basically arguing that you have
this past trauma. You're totally you're totally invested in this
emotionally. You stupid [__] You can't see you can't
see straight at all. And then it's like, well, he actually has
past trauma that would make him invested in the exact position
he's taking, which is kind of dubious. Not that he has to disclose,
but he's already disclosed, so
it's a bit weird >> because, and this is the funniest of
all the time stamps I have with him. Check this out. >> By
the way, also Britney knows that, right? It sounds like I believe
Britney says earlier in this that she knows things that have
not been disclosed about Destiny around trauma and stuff that
she's never going to release on the internet that she doesn't
think anybody should be mocked for. She kind of hints at like
a very very very specific thing. Okay. So, when you're Britney
sitting there and somebody who's told you about this is mocking
you directly for being emotional because of your trauma, right?
And you I I think it's something to have the strength not to
go, wait, isn't there some trauma that you have that might be
biasing you here? if she knows about that same thing. There's
a real argument that she was the bigger person there. Although
maybe not because I guess Britney was more public about it, right?
So >> because Destiny,
>> what happened? Um Destiny just has probably similar
trauma to Britney Simon that would have biased him in that conversation.
Maybe in the opposite direction. Like maybe he had buried that
trauma himself and said it doesn't affect him and there's no
reason to believe it would affect him and everybody could be
normal. Anybody could be normal after something like that, right?
Yeah, I'm sure that drama is already released. It is already
released. It is already broadly known
>> And all of these people >> Yeah. That doesn't
mean her rationale for having that conversation was good or that
she was correct in that conversation. It just means that Destiny
probably had a similar bias to her that wasn't disclosed and
made a bunch of people go he's right. Instead of just saying
Britney's wrong, people are saying he's right. Right.
>> Get to exist in a bubble where this is their reality.
Check this out. >> Be self-aware of the fact that like
people aren't because they feel Okay. >> you have to like
you have to be aware that like every people are doing things
for reasons. There's no random [__] right? It's not
like like the Nazis weren't like uniquely evil or you know like
serial killers don't just >> I love being random. No one
just do stuff. I just do stuff all the time. >> Sure people
probably going to be things going on. >> I would imagine
a good idea biology like there's reasons why people act and it's
and it's important imperative even to uncover those reasons and
understand those reasons. Otherwise, you're like missing a huge
part of the picture of existence, I guess. >> Absolutely.
So, that that basically is why I have I think such an obsession
about the human condition like what it means to exist and be
a person. So, I have to ask, do you enjoy existing? >> Yes,
absolutely. >> What about existence itself? Do you enjoy
that? >> Yeah, for sure. >> Really? What is it about
existence that you like? For the definition for the audience,
existence would be everything outside of Stephen, everything
outside of me. So, Stephen is like existence and I'm interacting
with him. your existence audience and I'm interacting with you.
So, what is it about existence that you don't seem to be bothered
by? >> I um I don't know why I'm just lucky, I guess, but
I have a very very high like day-to-day experience. Like my mental
is very high. My enjoyment of things are very high. When I wake
up, I'm excited to do things. Um I like everything I do every
day. Like I'm just like a very very high like mentally functioning
person, I guess. So, yeah. So, I tend to enjoy everything related
to life and existence and all that. >> Okay. Interesting.
Can I ask about your mental health background? Like do you have
any like fun diagnoses or anything like that that you share with
the >> Um nope. I'm pretty normal I think. >> What's
that like? >> Um pretty good actually. I guess it seems
to be uh pretty >> So let's talk about this. Pretty normal.
Nope. I got nothing going on because he avoided any opportunity
to get diagnosed even though it's clear and this is a lot of
empathy. I'm saying this with a lot of empathy. He had a very
up childhood. I cannot
I cannot exaggerate enough how bad his childhood was. It was
so bad. And there look there are things about Natalie and Steven
that I will never share with the internet that they told me in
confidence that genuinely the internet should never know about
them. >> Oh, here it is. Yes. See,
>> we are talking about mental health and I am very empathetic
to that because I am BPD in remission. Okay. DBT saved my life.
I am autistic, late diagnosed. I'm fibromyalgia. I've lived in
a very like mid dysfunctional home. I know what it's like to
have to deconstruct your childhood. It's hard. So,
>> h this is um this is a little this is a little crazy
to me that like she's clearly she's clearly pointing at she's
also clearly pointing at something here which is uh >> being
very empathetic to that, right? >> Just mention it. Just
mention it. Just say it. >> Um, but I want you to understand
that people get to exist on the internet without any responsibility.
>> Simon only lied about having lupus once. I will never
forget that. >> And even after he got an ADHD diagnosis,
obviously, okay, he like downplays it or uses it as an excuse
to get away with stuff. So, let me make this clear. I'm going
to bring this all together. Thank you for staying with me. Thank
you for being here, guys. If you have any comments or questions,
you need clarifications, I will answer them because I think all
of this is very human. And I think we have to stop pretending
like this isn't happening. There's no such thing as a normal
person. There's no such thing as a person who got to be raised
without dysfunction. There's no such thing as a person who exists
in the world that doesn't have problems. Okay? We all have pro.
We hate Britney Simon. Is she based? Uh we're mostly justifying
our positions on her whole fallout with Destiny. mostly like
explaining what we think about it and waiting for her to get
to the part where she starts explaining how she breaks up with
people online, how she breaks up with other content creators
because she's going to leak some stuff about it. She's going
to talk about it and basically how how she has some down some
down opinions on some of the people from the Destiny universe.
>> problems. The question is, are we going to get to the
healthier side of our problems, which I recommend we all do because
it's a life-changing experience. Okay, and I think I'm living
proof of that. Now, there's two ways I want to move forward with
this conversation. is one I want to show you how I normally end
relationships with content creators, okay? When things are shifting
because I think it's important and I want you to recognize uh
that not everybody has to do this way, but this is how I do it,
>> When I I gave So, Destiny burned the bridge with me
and behind closed doors. I genuinely >> Hold on just real
quick quick update on on this one. Uh what did I ask? Oh, yeah.
Yeah, here we go. I just listen. I can be the bigger man here.
Hey Willie, do you want to comment on this post about how you're
like saying things about the lawsuit like it's incredibly justified
for them to include that picture of without having read it? You
dumb
you illiterate [__] Anyway, we're having a good time.
Let's go back. >> Believed he would one day come around.
The same way I genuinely believed one day Contra would come around.
The same way I genuinely believed the people who had done inappropriate
things would eventually realize it was bad. And then they never
did. Then they never did. And I'm like, "Okay, so are you not
going to get better?" Okay, remember that Steven and Abba at
the time were >> Why is that the first comeback? Because
Willie is unoriginal, low IQ. He's incapable of actual discussion.
Yeah, obviously that's why that's the first comeback. But I I'll
just I'll just continue to point out that he is running consistently
running. Willy's running
>> Upset with me for remaining hopeful about Sneo. Remember
who remembers the moment I stopped talking to Sneo and the moment
I took down our collabs together? It was the moment two women
came forward about the way that he abused them. That's it. That's
all I needed. I didn't want men on the internet who were already
misogynistic to be lecturing me about giving Sneo a chance because
I was giving both Abba and Destiny a chance. But they didn't
process it that way. These boys didn't process that I'm >> She
also goes at Abba here quite hard. all of you a chance of you
a chance to get better. >> And the fact that you don't
know that is so interesting to me. And then I cut everybody off.
Now, when Destiny uh when I realized Destiny wasn't going to
get better, when I realized he was going to double down, when
I realized he wasn't going to admit what he did was wrong, by
the way, he had an affair with Lauren Su at the time that he
was telling me everything is good and life is good. He was literally
having an affair with Lauren Southern. His wife was coming to
me asking me how to fix her marriage. You know, every >> I
just think the up part about this was where Molina was like,
I think you're having an affair with Lauren Southern. I think
you're you're not telling me about this. And he was like, no,
you're crazy. You need therapy. You're actually insane, Molina.
You're actually insane. >> Everybody was worried about
him. But the thing about Steven is that he just plays it off
like it's all fine. And who can blame any of us for being interested
in Steven or wanting to give him a chance? You know what I mean?
Um, it's really easy to be swept up by Steven. I I just made
my own choices and uh built my own >> if Assan could be
swept up. If this intelligent massive human being could be swept
up, couldn't anyone >> businessman I guess if I were to
use a term like that? I paved it on my own because I thought
like this is a concept that I think is cool gaming. This is a
concept that I think you can marry uh >> literally paved
it on his own commentary. Let's go. >> I paved it on my
own. Paved it on my
>> Chad says Abba's book spoke about what Disney Destiny
did was wrong. No, he didn't. You think he did, but I'm gonna
show you today that he didn't. >> He He You fell for it.
You fell for him thinking he was standing up against what Destiny
did. I'll show you how Abba actually didn't. >> Paved it
on my own.
>> Shout out Shout out to Destiny, by the >> Kyle
Kolinsky, Triex, do you remember the situation with this? Okay,
Kyle Kolinsky, Destiny have definitely had their moments together.
Shout out to Kyle Kolinsky. Okay, Hassan.
Destiny definitely helped Hassan rise to prominence, but when
Destiny wouldn't stop saying the word, Triex and Hassan were
like, "What are you doing?" And it became like a whole thing.
Okay. Right. Mikey membership for 17 months says, "Do you feel
like you ever want to uh rekindle the relationships you had with
these men if they ever show actual growth and change or is it
uh curtains?" Curtains, baby. And this is what I mean to say.
I am more than happy to talk about path. >> Oh, there is
no there's no comeback for ABBA. He'll never he'll never be back
in the circle >> of redemption. I am not willing to do
any of the emotional labor. I am more than happy to explain to
the internet, not through DMs, but to the internet ways I would
recommend redemption for these people, but I in no way am interested
in doing any of the emotional labor. Do not DM me. Anybody I
mention in this video, I will not respond to your DMs most likely,
unless it's Cadlac, cuz I love her or FD or somebody, but nobody
else. Okay? I'm not doing this so I can get your DMs. I'm doing
this so I can explain something that I think is important for
all of civilization, not just YouTube. YouTube is just civilization
on the micro, guys. >> All civilization.
>> Let's go. I love pretty. >> This is incredibly
niche. I can't imagine it being useful for literally anyone else.
>> This is great times. Okay.
Only JTO could get that much motion with the True. I wish I could,
but I cannot.
YouTube is civilization on the micro. I don't even think that's
what to say. Civil YouTube's like a cutout of culture at any
given time and that's indicative of where the culture is going.
You think civilization is culture which a lot of people would
argue. Okay. >> On the macro it's the same. Look what just
happened with Elon and Trump. >> Same thing that's happening
here except somebody has the nuclear codes. Pay
>> Oh yeah. I forgot to say. Yeah. >> Oh you know
you know of them. Okay cool. But when I watched that video I
was like oh that's cool. So we have like somebody in the gaming
community who's actually pushing back. >> Hell yes. That's
actually Destiny's a reason why I know about Trix. >> Were
you playing SE 7 again? Would they do some expansions to make
the game >> Um I might play Sim 6 again at some point.
Sim 6 is just better right now. >> Well, if Destiny was
my roommate, I get him laid all the time. >> I uh I I was
like, "All right, whatever. Well, I don't have anything. Like
I I don't have anything. I have no option. I'm in the next 11
days." So much so that like Stephen was uh DMing me on Discord
and saying, "Hey, you know what? If you don't have a place to
live, buddy, like, you can come stay with me. It's okay. What
a >> Okay, that's what Wait, >> is she gonna watch
the entire paved on my own thing again? >> Good guy. Destiny
is >> No way. >> Great guy. >> Okay, so for
all those people that were like, I can't trust Britney Simon.
She knew Destiny. We all knew Destiny.
I don't know why we all got sucked into his little place, but
we all got Okay, I don't blame Hassan. You know, I even DM' Destiny
one time because I only learned about Hassan really through Destiny.
And I was like, is Hassan a narcissist? Destiny's like, no, I
don't think so. I think he just like, you know, whatever, whatever.
I don't remember what he said. And I just remember thinking like,
man, who is this Hassan guy? And then I did my research outside
of the Destiny orbit and I was like, oh yeah, all of you are
kind of just men at the end of the day, but Hassan is a better
man. And that, you know, but he's still a man, but he's a better
man. And I think that's significant. Okay, being a consent violator,
huge deal. Destiny is literally a consent violator. Like huge
deal, right? Okay. beat. >> So, uh, Maser 1123 with 10
gifted. Let's go, Maser. Thank you very much. Let's Let's go.
That is 10 gifted. That is another two hours on the stream. Thanks
to Mer's big gift and the the two individual subs we got earlier
today. Thank you very much, Mer. Appreciate you. Appreciate the
support. Let's
go. >> There's so many things to get to today. I think
that is the same donation coming through a second time, but we
still appreciate the support from Mer. Thank you very much. >> We
are all guilty of interacting with this weasly little liar, dude.
Okay? And I'm not going to fault us for trying. I think we should
continue to try. I think we should continue to try. I think we
should continue to be better. I think we should try to build
bridges. I just think we should be cautious with who we build
bridges >> with. Evol >> building bridges. >> Jet
says, "No lie, when I saw you, Destiny, I definitely judged because
I already had >> uh two gifted coming in from Space Ghost.
Thank you very much, Space Ghost. Appreciate it. Appreciate it.
>> And there's way more. Uh it's another 10 from Cyber
Drifter right after Space Ghost. So that is 12. That's another
60 >> That is another hour on the stream. Oh my god.
>> There's There's donations coming in from every direction
right now. I don't even know how to handle it. >> What
the hell? Let's go. Thank you very much, guys, for all the support.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. That's uh what is that? That's
three more hours in the stream. That's 5 hours 54 minutes 56
seconds. Thank you very much for the support. We are
I think I've reset the top one. Oh, wait. I missed out on $15
there. $1575. Stream hours plus one. I think I did my math correctly.
I think we have $15 in the last hour of the stream, but there's
three hours from all the generous support. Cyberdrifter, Space
Ghost, and Mer. Thank you guys very much again. Meters get reset.
>> Certain picture of the type of people that surrounded
him. Fair. >> 100% fair. Y'all, if you're mad at me for
collabing with Destiny, you should be. I'm mad at me, too. I'm
that. Me too, girl.
I don't blame you. I'm mad, too. >> So, when I put out
my video about Destiny, that was in November.
>> I finally was ready to talk about it in like a real
way and say like, look, I'm sick of knowing these this man's
secrets. I just want to be done with this space alone. And I
made a really great video that Hassan ignored, which is fine.
Interesting that Hassan watched Ryan Beard's video, but not mine.
It's fine. Maybe my video was boring. probably was, you know,
I thought it was a good video, but whatever. And I wanted out
of the space. And then Lauren Southern allegations came out.
Proof came out with the receipts because I talked about Lauren
Southern, but I didn't have the receipts. Then the receipts showed
up. All the DMs got leaked. It was all out there. Okay. And then
everything started, you know, his revenge stuff, him recording
women without their consent and sharing the videos. All of it
started to come out.
>> this is important.
The DMs I'm about to show you did only took place before
>> the allegations and right after I put out my video for
the initial allegations of being apologist and stuff. >> Got
it. >> Okay. So I Okay, I Britney am showing you DMs which
I know is very uncou, but I think it's necessary. >> Why
does she think Hassan even knows of her existence? She's not
as big as Ryan Beard. I think Hassan's been linked her videos
and stuff and pulled them up on stream videos, tweets, whatever.
because I'm trying to paint my character here.
I think this all ties into contra and tabernacle and everything
else we're doing here. This is going to be a long stream, girls.
I really I'm gonna go hard today. Okay, >> so I put out
my video and I waited to see how people reacted to it. And of
course, I started to cut off every single person that stood by
Destiny after that point. So, here was the message I wrote to
Tom Fullery as an example of how I communicate with people. I
saw Tom do a video uh stream reacting to my video. I didn't appreciate
his
>> take away from it. >> Tom Foolery got axed from
the Britney orbit. Damn. >> He said, "Hey, Tom. I saw you
react to my latest video on Destiny. I appreciate you giving
it a watch. Moving into 2025, I'm narrowing down my work connections
and looking to collab with people who share uh similar views,
especially on topics as important as abuse, apology, and misogyny.
Based on your review of my video, it seems we are not aligned.
Uh I >> that's cool. Britney's come over to my side. Okay,
listen. I I feel like we really shouldn't support people who
support abuse, apology, and misogyny, Tom. And because of that,
I don't want to be anywhere near you, Tom.
I wish you the best, and I hope nothing but happiness for you
heading into 2025.
I'm a very [__] nice communicator, okay? I almost
always send people a letter saying, "Thank you for our time together.
I'd like to move on." Okay, that's basically how I end connections
with people. Okay,
when I made my video about Destiny, >> she broke up with
Tom. >> I got I sent Kyla a message. I sent a bunch of
people messages.
But actually, fun fact, Abba reached out to me before I had a
chance to reach out to him. And he sent me this video or this
message. And this we had talked for a bit. He sent me a message
that said, "Oh, I see I'm in a Britney Simon video." I said,
"Yes. Did you watch it?" Like, "I'm this something very serious
is happening." And this is before, you need to hear me. This
is before we knew about Destiny recording women and sharing it.
So, this is AB and I having a conversation
about everything else. Okay? The apologia and his videos. Um,
making fun of Kelly Jean, who I understand is not a good person.
That doesn't make her less of a
>> Excuse me.
Kelly's Kelly's I shouldn't use that word, but Kelly is destroyed.
>> Yeah. Could you not picked a different
>> I'm sorry. Listen, the the vocabulary is the vocabulary.
That's my bad. But uh Kelly's destroyed. Okay. Kelly's owned.
Get wrecked, Kelly. >> She doesn't like me because she
lied about having lupus. Who says they have lupus without a diagnosis?
That's stupid and insane.
>> Uh I don't know much about that. I'd have to look into
that. Unfortunately, >> she admitted it and she said her
and her doctor used to call it the lupus between them and then
it turned out to not be that. I don't know why it took a year
for her to figure out that's not what she had. But >> yeah,
cuz it's just an ANA test, right? But I Yeah, I don't know. I
don't know. I don't know. >> Why do you know that? Have
you been listening to me?
>> No. I destroyed you, Kelly. I eviscerated you in the
House MD trivia questions. Okay, we did House MD trivia on stream.
I eviscerated you completely. >> That was all entire know
that >> that was entirely about just the social relationships.
There was no medical on there at all. >> No, there was
medical on there, but it wasn't medical. But if I watch House,
then why would I not know that? >> What does ANA stand
for?
antibodies, right? No, no, no, no.
>> Oh, god damn it. Oh, well, I tried. I tried to go off
the cuff. Couldn't do >> Um, Destiny
you know, doing what he did to me, all of the other stuff, right?
Like all of the the issues
that were there in that space. Okay. So, Abbott messaged me and
this is the message. He said, "I didn't watch most of it. I tried
to stay out of y'all's beef to be honest." And I tried to explain
to him it's not beef.
See, the dilemma is everybody keeps calling it beef. I need to
set a standard here that the problem with YouTube is the same
problem with
um
Vance and Trump making fun of Zalinsky for not having a suit.
It's all the same thing. You keep thinking it's just beef. We're
the adults in the room. And I don't know how to tell you all
this, but we're going to be 40. Do you want to be Ethan Klein
at 40?
We have got to grow up. And I'm working really hard to get rid
of my streamer language language and to grow up. One of the reasons
I don't watch Hassan is he's got too much streamer language and
I'm going to pick it up. Okay. My echoleia just copies everything
from accents to the ways people talk.
>> We have got to grow up. >> My echelia Myleia.
I don't know what that I don't know what that is. I don't I'm
unaware. And the problem is is like we're not going to do >> Sorry,
I'm downloading. I had to take a second there, guys, because
I had to go to my terminal and download the full the full
Candace Owens Nick Fuentes conversation. Okay, I've got the full
thing downloading right now. Okay, we can watch it later. Uh,
I think we can watch it. I will probably try to watch it. We
won't re-upload it anywhere, but we will we will have it. Okay,
downloading the full thing right now. I should have set that
up in the background. My commentary has been a little sparse,
but it'll pick up. >> Certainly not if the world leaders
aren't. But this is all connected. It's high school with money.
>> Um, what speed are we watching Britney on? Oh, sorry.
That was my computer. >> Oh, what speed are we watching
on? I don't know. Uh, one. I don't I can't really speed her up
a lot more and still understand her, but I can go 1.25. >> It's
high school with >> um Ogre Boy says it's an autism quirk
where you copy and repeat sounds. So, the echalleia is it's an
autism quirk where you copy and repeat sounds because you find
it soothing. Okay. And then they have the audacity to try to
throw around like these people are crazy. These people are crazy.
You're crazy. You're hanging out with us. Okay. I always wondered
why why Abba liked me or or Destiny since we're so nerd divergent.
Come to find out ABBA's ADHD. Of course he is. Of course he is.
Do you know what I mean? So
>> So I sent him this >> let's check it out >> message.
I said I'm running an event right now on Discord. So I'm not
sure I can send a voice note. of all type. I'm not sure if you're
saying that you don't know the full context and aren't or and
aren't interested in knowing. Or if you know the full context
but don't care. This isn't beef. This is a moral issue and abuse
is occurring. I'm not saying that Steven can't ever get better
change. I'm saying I won't do the work for him and no one else
should. Um I'm reading really small text on my >> uh unlock
gen chat. Is Gen Chat not unlocked right now? Oh, maybe Jen chat's
not unlocked right now. Yeah, you can unlock Gen Chat >> my
screen right now. So hold on. You guys are seeing it right though,
right? Hold on. You guys are seeing this, right? My text is really
small in my end. It says, um, >> I didn't watch most of
it. I'm just trying to read this again.
>> I'm slathering my face with lidocaine because it's the
only way to not suffer.
Everything is numb. It feels so weird. >> Yeah. Like I
think Abba's response is going to be mostly reasonable here.
Like it's going to be reasonable. He's going to say like, I'm
not really doing anything, but n we'll keep listening. >> All
abusers can recover and be better. Mostly, right? I said, did
you want to clarify your position and then we can we can move
on? I've always appreciated our connection and have appreciated
your content over the years, even when we disagree. I don't want
my bad I don't want any bad energy between us, even if we decide
never to connect again. Okay. He said, "Most of this uh most
of his personal life looks like dysfunction, mentally ill people.
Dysfunctional mentally ill people who are hellbent on lying and
hurting each other. So, I don't feel bad for them or Destiny
when they lie and cheat on each other." Kelly Jean especially.
This is She's a pathological liar.
>> What the Britney? >> She get she getting hit.
No. No. No. That's Abba. That's Aba. That's Abba. That's Aba.
Just to be clear, that's >> Aba said that. Why? >> Uh,
well, she's a path pathological liar in my experience with her.
So, if that's what this abuse stuff is about or Molina, I really
don't care to be honest. Oh, is he calling Molina a pathological
liar, too? Damn.
>> Well, this guy had a horrible read on a lot of things.
I wonder if he would take it back. >> Um, I'm sure if you
could get him So, it's one of those things where I think he wants
to be distanced, so he'll never look. If you ever had him invested
enough to relook at this, I do think like if he's totally like
burned his bridges, if he doesn't want to be around anywhere,
right, with with this group, I although I don't think it's necessarily
right, I understand why he wouldn't reevaluate, right? But I
think if you could show him the Ryan Beard nuke or something,
if you show him like these things showing the pattern of behavior
over time, it could become more clear that like, hey, it's a
little bit less of that, right? Like it's less that it's just
like a bunch of mentally ill people trying to hurt each other
or something. And it's more like, no, this guy's this guy's a
step above. Okay. He's a little special. He's a special mental
person. Mentally ill person who wants to hurt people around him.
Yeah. A little bit >> What I'm not sure about is what kind
of interaction I had with ABBA for him to think that way cuz
I thought he just got annoyed at like the transgender discussion.
I It didn't have anything to do with like lying.
>> that's is all he said. So, I don't know. It's just confusing.
>> Um OMFG's pro. I don't think a lot of people saw the
Anna messages laid out in like a dispassionate context to see
like that she was clearly the person being abused in that situation,
right? There's clearly somebody somebody making like really really
bad choices and and manipulating her. I don't think a lot of
people saw that. So yeah, it is what it is. What hospital does
Gregory House work in? Princon. Princeton. Princeton. Princeton.
Plansboro Hospital. Teaching hospital, actually. Okay. Um,
hold on. I'm looking. Oh, yeah. Aba wouldn't know all this context.
Trust me, he wouldn't know or you wouldn't have this opinion.
ABBA.
Yeah, he wouldn't have this opinion. Nerasar made a really good
comment though. Uh, ABBA basically did the old orbiter bit of
talking about how Destiny's conduct is really unhealthy for Destiny
himself. The only thing different is Abba not wanting to hurt
his reputation by continuing to associate with him with the pocket.
I think that is broadly probably what annoys people is it's like,
oh, this guy this guy like recorded a bunch of um without consent.
Yeah, that's um, you know, that's really bad for him. I don't
know why he did that. I think he could be better in the future.
It's like, "No, stop. Stop worrying about him. He's not like
the victim of those things. He could be the victim of other things,
but he's not the victim of those things." All right. Anyway,
we continue. >> In my experience with her, and I understand
that, right? Like, I have no I I'm not trying to defend Kelly
Gene, but that doesn't mean she's not a victim, right? He said
basically, I don't care. >> Oh, Britney at least gave you
that one. Doesn't mean she's not a victim. Let's >> Yeah.
Oh, was this around the time of like the Full Thought stuff or
something? Like this was like these dates. This looks like around
when the forthought and I came on. It was Pixie and Luna Box.
You came on as well. >> I came up. I didn't want to be
a part of that at all.
>> Uh well, whatever. I You were there at some point. I
don't know. Dad. >> Oh, no. I wasn't there actually. I
didn't join that stream. I streamed about it after.
>> Anyway, the question is this is the that time, right?
It's November
or December?
>> Oh, wait. No, maybe I did go on then. >> Yeah,
it's November or December. I don't know. Okay, >> this
is after the election, so it's probably It must have been before
that, right? Must have been before the election. Maybe not. I
actually don't >> The It was early November. >> It
was early. >> Yeah, the forth thought thing happened like
a couple weeks before like everyone found out Destiny shared
all the sex tapes, right? It might even been less than two weeks,
but it was not long after.
That's why it was so like general, right? >> It's right
around this. But I don't I don't know if he would even be aware
of that stuff. There's nothing to say that he would even like
certainly be aware of that stuff at all. So, >> um, but
if you feel differently about the gravity of what guys, hold
on. Let >> Sorry. Wait. There's no reason to believe you
be Why are you Why do you think that's relevant? I don't I don't
>> because she's talking about me being a victim. I assume
that's what that's about like the sexual >> also just like
Destiny like
like on you and using you get abused by his community kind of
thing. Like I I could see her believing that. Absolutely. Right.
I mean, she started out talking about assault and like actual
trauma, not just being traumatized, but you >> I'm sure
she'd believe you on that, too. I'm sure she doesn't think you're
like a liar about that. >> Yeah. Yeah, that could be what
she's referring to. Anyway, we continue. >> My I can't
read this. It's too small for my eyes. Hold on. >> I mean,
he said also he says pathological liar in my experience with
her. So, he said he's stating that as his experience, not just
what he's learned through Destiny videos. So that's really weird
cuz we didn't really have that many interactions which is strange.
Yeah, I have no idea what he's accusing me of lying about. Very
old. You right. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> I just had
a time carrier out of the Discord here. >> Yes, I Oh, >> I'll
read it on my wondering what you were doing.
Here I am trying to like scrunch my eyes like a little old lady.
I need glasses, bro. Okay. He said, um, but if you feel differently
about the gravity of what he's doing and all the seriousness
of it, like I said, I get it, but I just don't share your view.
I get it, but I just don't share your view. I think abuse is
abuse. And I said, Britney said, I think abuse is abuse no matter
who you're abusing. I also consider what he did to me abusive,
even just as a co-orker. I never lied about him. I tried my best
to stick up to my values and he retaliated without hesitation
and paid me without mercy as somebody that I wasn't. I understand
that I might not be something that's important to you or I understand
that might not be something that's important to you and I think
that's actually fair as we aren't close. And then I said, "Hold
on, girlies." Boomer Britney moving very slowly through these
receipts. Then I said,
"Boom." Then I said, "Give me a second. Um, I moving forward,
I wish you health and happiness. Thank you for every positive
moment together. I'll remember our moments fondly." Boom. Okay,
that's the end. Right. So then >> when was the Abba Drake
conversation? Cuz I wonder if that's somewhere around here. Hold
on. Abba, Destiny, Drake. When was that combo?
That was
a year ago.
>> what does this mean by a year ago? May 8th, 2024. This
was 6 months before these DMs. Okay, >> that was it. Okay,
that was the end of Aba and I connecting. Okay, that's how I
handle conflict to the best of my ability. I'm not always perfect,
but that's that's like a pretty I think that was a pretty good
way to handle the situation. Okay. >> Yeah, I don't think
I don't think I mean other than ABBA's comments basically saying
like bad reads on the situation. I think he had really bad reads
on the situation overall, but I do think that his responses to
Britney of like, "Yeah, I understand why you'd want to do that
and I don't I'm not mad at you and I'd have the same response
for him if he said these same things to me." So, I don't think
that's a horrible um response to Britney specifically.
>> Okay. So, remember, I think we're all high schoolers
with money and status. And I it like that's the important part
here because it was such a disappointment to see, right? Um
ABBA's reaction to when the allegations actually came out against
Destiny because in Abba's video about Destiny's allegations and
him burning the bridge with Destiny, it wasn't because he was
a predator. It was because he was bad for Abba's brand. That
was the disappointment part. So, let me let's talk about that.
Remember, I'm not friends with these people. Like, I need you
to understand, we're not friends. Abba and Kyla are friends with
Dest or Destiny. I am not a friend. Nobody established a real
friendship with me. They establish a cordial YouTube friendship
with me. >> I wonder if she is basically saying for everybody,
I'm using my definition of friend or if she's like using their
I don't even know how this is working. >> We don't talk
to each other. They don't learn about >> seconds here.
I'm just going to get some coffee with my partner. Like, we don't
have that kind of relationship. But Abba and Kyla were doing
that. Chad says, "I keep thinking you were close to them. Maybe
that's why it felt abrupt. That's the problem. That's the illusion
I am trying to get you guys to understand. The illusion is that
we're close. We're not close.
That's why I'm annoyed with these people on the internet because
the audience thinks we're close. They play it like we're close.
I'm sorry. You don't even know me. Maybe you guys are close to
each other, but y'all aren't close to me. And you keep dragging
me into your beef like we're close. And then when I call out
the abuse, you're like, "I can't believe my friend did this to
me." We're not close. Kylie and I, we tried. We couldn't get
there. I just couldn't trust Kyla. She was too defensive of Destiny,
you know, like I couldn't get there. Kidology, we never got close.
I never got close to these people. We did not talk, guys. We
were not the beef. Now, some YouTubers I do have a couple of
YouTubers, actually just one right now, that we actually do like
chat. We we talk on a pretty okay frequent basis. And I'm we're
attempting to have a very good friendship and I I hope it goes
well, right? But most people nah, I'm not friends with these
people. Okay? And that's what I'm trying to make you understand.
And this is what's happening. That's why when Trump goes, "Elon
and I, we were so we were friends. Elon and I, we were like so
close." No, they're not, you know. No, they're not. That's what
I'm saying. And that's what I'm trying to get you to understand.
This whole thing is absolutely what's happening globally. It's
happening in your family's relationships. It's happening with
presidents. It's happening everywhere. You are pedestaling your
parents without understanding they haven't deconstructed. You're
giving elders, you know, status in the community when they haven't
earned it. Okay? You're giving Trump credit when him and are
fighting like losers on the internet. Okay? It's all a game and
the game is a we're all participating in it and I'm saying it's
not a game. It's the fact that we keep refusing that it's happening.
>> Okay, I'm back. What the is the beef? That's the only
thing I can think that whole time I walked away and came back.
What the is the beef? I don't know what the beef is. What the
>> And we're not maturing or getting healthier. Dr. Kiranda
tried to participate in a way he thought was good and he got
bullied into post privating his video because Ethan threatened
him. Because Ethan is that kind of person. And I'm saying I want
to talk about y'all, but I don't want to be with y'all. I want
to talk about it. I don't want to get involved in it with peace
and love. I think I think I'm really trying to do stuff out here,
okay? You know, I think I I think I in 20 years will have something
really productive to show, but for now, just think of me as a
girly doing research and having like a an interest in this bubble,
but I'm not here to be a part of the I don't want to be a player,
you know?
>> And then somehow people like drag me in. But then see
how des >> I think it's one of those things where you can't
observe it without also seeing things or also having people respond,
right? You you can't say I want to do commentary and not have
people respond to me. That's not really a fair or okay thing
to say. You'd say I don't want to do collaborations with these
people, but you are going to be a part of it if you comment on
it. Blamed me. Lindsay blamed me. And I'm like are none of you
going to hold yourselves accountable? I am a nobody. I'm just
But because I'm a nobody, I think it's easy for people to be
like you needed Destiny to build your career. I had a whole career.
I literally was a full-time content creator before I met him.
You know what I mean? You know, Chess says, "And you're disappointed
in Aba. It took the girls coming forward publicly to believe
Destiny was toxic because he didn't believe you." Hey, I don't
know what you're missing from this conversation, but let me show
you ABBA's videos to get an idea because it's like the um
I'm I'm allowed to be disappointed in people. I'm disappointed
in politicians all the time. I'm disappointed in neighbors. I'm
disappointed in a lot of people. You're allowed to be disappointed
in people. But ABBA wants credit where credit is not due.
Done beat. >> What is this? Space Ghost gifted another
sub. Thank you very much, Space Ghost. Appreciate it, buddy.
>> And you give him credit when credit is not due. He wasn't
listening to people. Lots of women came forward. Myself included.
I made excuses thinking I I just believe Destiny. Okay. So, we're
all responsible for not doing the due diligence. The difference
is I at least thought I was a little bit more of a credible source,
but I guess I was just another girl. Abba didn't >> I I
do think Abba can do this, right? Where he's just like super
dismissive. I get that he's like sort of um recovering incel.
I know Sophia made that point that like he's recovering incel
kind of had a lot of these opinions. I don't need him I don't
need him to make like any
specific decisions. Right. Britney isn't taking accountability
for her part. I think man I don't know. I don't know if it's
okay to like go and give people Man, it's hard to say. It's really
difficult to say whether or not I think it's okay to like give
somebody an ultimatum like this cuz would they rather you not
say anything? I don't know. It is actually It's actually difficult
to know for sure. Anyway, >> changed his mind because girls
came forward. He changed his mind because Destiny was facing
a felony. He changed his mind because it was bad for his brand.
Okay. And I'll show you that in a second. Let me get it out.
Um, hold on. I have so many videos. And wait until I get to CJ
the X and FD Signifier, who I love. Well, I love FD. Wait until
I get into that. Not that I'm going to have receipts on them,
but I'm going to have a point I'm going to make with them wanting
to build a bridge with Kyla, who still won't refuse to stand
with Destiny. We'll talk about that. Okay. This is all connected,
girls. It's all
Okay, just >> I love when she randomly sings. That's my
favorite part of a Britney Simon song or stream is when she randomly
starts singing the things the words she's going to say. Yep.
That's my favorite part. Is that your guys' favorite part? It's
my favorite part. I love that part. >> It's a reminder
of who Abba is. Hold on. This is like really important. I was
definitely disappointed when Abba and I
hang on. I do word association.
So, if someone says certain words, then I do it. But only usually
if it's going to be funny. And it was funny singing ironic. Okay.
That was a good one. >> Guys are a hard crowd. >> And
the disappointment started pretty early. So, I always knew ABBA
and Preach were transphobes and homophobes. But I saw a great
change in them, right? I saw an amazing change and I was like,
"Oh, they're growing." But it wasn't enough. And y'all used to
call me out on that, right? you all kept trying to tell me Britney
Ab and Preach aren't, you know, they're not learning, they're
not doing good. And I was like, well, maybe they will though.
Fingers crossed. Like, maybe they will. And I really believed
in that and I still believe in it. I just don't want to do the
emotional labor. But I was doing it. Every time AB and I would
talk, I would really try to see him where he was coming from
and give him his flowers. But we obviously disagreed. It was
like I was the progressive in the bubble that nobody treated
like a progressive. And then I realized it's like, oh, cuz you
guys aren't progressive. I knew ABBA wasn't progressive, but
I kept thinking there must be something progressive here, right?
Like there must be something here and like that's the problem.
What is it? So then I saw what would be um FD signifier say that
he would debate Destiny if Destiny donated. >> Oh,
Britney's not going to like this
>> This was like kind of weird. I don't >> Here's
the video. I'll show it to you. It's going to be loud. Hold on.
>> Come on stream. >> After you donate 25K to community
movement builders here in Atlanta
>> Okay. So FD says, "If you raise $25 $25,000,
right, for activists, I will come on your show." And I thought,
"Damn, that's really good, right?
That's really good. That's amazing." And what did Aba and Destiny
do? They donated $10,000 to the cops. >> I think I think
ABBA just lied about it. I think Abba came out and said he was
just lying about it, right? Aba just lied and didn't actually
make that donation. Pretty sure. Pretty sure >> this is
Destiny. Okay. Sorry for the delay, FD. Some of us work and have
busy lives though. Can't believe you couldn't wait 4 days for
your 10,000 anti police police fund donation. So, I went ahead
and just dated 10k to the Atlanta Police Department. Okay. Right.
That is the thing. I That's so gross. That's so gross. Right.
>> I just think it's like weird. It's just like a weird
out for content that could have been content. I don't know. It
just weird. It was just weird. >> And what's even crazier
is like ABBA had the audacity and continues to have the audacity
to be like, I'm not one of them, but I'm in there. I I personally
find it weird just in that like if you say you're going to do
something to like go and do the opposite is just is like weird.
But I don't have like I thought it like I I could see it being
funny. I don't have like a problem with it. It's just like to
I don't know why he wouldn't do the content. He just didn't do
the content. So I just would have wanted to see the content more
than anything. I'm like content focused, you know? It's weird
to be like, "Oh, you I'm actually not doing the content." But
also to be fair to ABBA, he did somewhat to hold himself accountable
for even being in it in the first place. But >> FD is like
a whiny [__] though. So, and >> hold on, wait.
I don't want to lose my train of thought. Wait. FD Signifier
ABBA. I just thought of something else. I'll remember again.
I'm really going off the cuff here. This is what ABBA put out
um after uh basically the victims of Destiny came out. >> Title.
I stand behind it. It's not B. It's not. >> It says Destiny
Bridge burning >> joke. Destiny is getting cancelled. All
right. And uh the reason being this time is that he supposedly
had intimate relationship with some women. And what he would
do is when he would film intimate moments with these ladies,
record them, he would share some of these with other women he
was approaching. And one case he shared it with a 19-year-old
egirl who he had never met in his life and he was flirting with
her and shared videos of himself sleep with another person without
their consent. >> See, I just appreciate ABBA having the
facts off the bat. Okay, we the bar was not high for initial
responses. >> Essentially, the 19-year-old gets hacked
and that stuff goes public. The person who was in the videos
finds out. lose her mind files a lawsuit asking Destiny for a
lot a huge sum of money. Um and then you know it comes out there
after the Destiny appearance. >> Listen to the language.
Loses her mind ask Destiny for a bunch of money already. The
misogyny is coming out. Do you do you know what I'm saying? That's
the misogyny of it all. >> That Aba does have some latent
misogyny.
Um but you know I really can't throw the first stone on that
one. I can't cast the first stone on that. I shouldn't throw
rocks in glass houses. That kind of thing, you know. You know.
So >> listen to the framing. Listen to the framing and
tell me that I'm not annoyed with these men who are shocked that
I think they're all misogynists. >> He had also recorded
a lot of other women while they were in his apartments without
their consent. So this has kind of gotten bigger and bigger since
warbeck me specifically. Where's breach? Preach busy. >> So
they've been gone for a few weeks, but look at the way he's handling
this video. So Aban preachification
and then this thing happened and everybody was like, is Abba
going to say something? Look at the way he did. >> Uh,
sure. Karate Moses. Yeah, I'm I'm Listen, I'm not taking offense.
I'm not taking offense. I don't think I took offense when it
happened. >> Down plays a video. He dances. It's funny.
It's all lighthearted. Your friend is a predator.
Our coworker is a predator. Our coworker is a predator. And you
are downplaying it. I had no idea this was happening. I don't
think Abba knew either. >> I get where Britney's coming
from. I do get it. I understand why she is upset. I just think
like it's probably accurate that he's downplaying it. It's like
I would look at other kind of like tragedies to see how I'm guessing
Abba's like entire personality is like being calm, cool, collect
a lot of the time, right? Like I think I think uh I think that
is so I will say that. But I understand why she's mad. I don't
really have a lot of heat for Britney being upset here. Oh, Benny's
here. Benny said the same thing. Benny uh did not like that video.
Benny hated that ABBA video. >> But when I found out, I
was so mortified. I was devastated because like now you start
wondering >> downplaying it. Aba burnt that bridge pretty
hard. Um, wait.
If let's say Israel really did nuke Gaza
and the United States like cut off aid to them. If they said
we're cutting off aid with Israel because they've taken military
action that we disagree with, that wouldn't really be appropriate
response, right? That wouldn't be appropriate. It's like, yeah,
you can you can distance yourself from something and say that
like, hey, it's bad, but you you probably should accurately sum
summarize it, right? You should be able to accurately say what's
going on. The downplaying can be downplaying even if you distance
entirely. Obviously,
I just don't I don't have the same energy for the ABA video,
but I I get >> Did he record me? Am I being recorded? I
heard he was recording people in his bathroom allegedly and I
was like, I use his bathroom and I was like sitting there like,
what the hell is happening? It was so devastating. Okay. And
look at ABBA coming out. >> You know what I mean? Out there
doing gay with his wife and me. I'm here for you guys right now.
>> Okay. So, he's like showing videos of Preach having
fun on vacation. >> I can go spend time on the internet
to talk about white-on-white violence. You are bugging. And if
you guys are wondering where Preach is, >> okay, like Q,
Preach is having fun, but like this is serious. Can you please
>> Uh, one woman that each of us are going to defend in
our lives. For him, it's his wife. For me, it's a it's a streamer
named Destiny. And, you know, we got to do our job. So, I this
is my responsibility. I'm going to handle her. Now, some of you
guys know, you know, Destiny is a friend of mine. Okay? And you
might be confused why I decided to come out dripped out from
my friend's cancellation. You know what I'm saying? >> I
remember seeing a video from Abram Preach. I couldn't >> stop
showing up, Britney. We could be on your side, Britney. Please
>> find it. But I remember >> I this I'm pretty good
at. I know a lot of other people aren't capable of doing this.
I'm pretty good at just like like letting go of tone or analyzing
tone in like a different category. I'll listen to what Britney
actually says and I will analyze it. Okay. But for me, like the
same thing with Abba, like tone doesn't always matter to me.
I can analyze that as a separate thing for Britney here. I don't
really need to analyze the tone. I get that she's being soy.
It doesn't really prevent me from watching the video. I understand
some people might >> I think so highly of ABA. And it was
a video about not inviting people to the get together who you
know did badit and I thought he's going to stand up for justice.
I had seen so many videos of ABBA saying he would stand up for
victims and I wanted to believe him. So when I saw this I was
like >> when I reached out to him I was like do you know
what I mean? Chad says imagine what the boys talked about when
you weren't there. That's what I mean. >> Is it nothing
burger? Um, I would say it's a nothing burger in that the the
thing ABBA could be argued to be doing wrong. It shouldn't be
something that like upsets most people. It's just like you kind
of on a personal level go uh I don't really like that. Right.
I would say probably her summation that he's like downplaying
is accurate. It's just like down. Again,
I just don't know how outside of his normal behavior it is, how
like consequential it is to anything else it could. And Abba
would just be fine with saying, "Oh, if you think that's downplaying,
you want to judge me for it. Sure.
So, I don't know. I'm I'm kind of kind of leaning into my humans
going to gonna human energy right now. Okay. Watch Britney one
time for one hour and suddenly it's humans going to human. You'll
love to see it. >> God knows. God knows. Okay. And I get
it. And by the way, look, I know. And I'm not never >> looking
kind of fresh. And again,
you >> this is a friend and people want to hear my opinions.
And I'll be honest with you, for all the bad things that are
happening in Destiny, I don't feel bad. Um, the reason why I
don't feel >> and I will say nothing in private ever happened
with ABBA that was bad. Like I I will say that he was really
nice. He was incredibly generous and very kind and we did um
this is when we went to Miami, we shared an airbnb together.
He was an incredible gentleman, okay? Very courteous, paid for
the Airbnb, you know, very just like generous, right? Very nice
person. um spent the whole weekend talking to me about D and
D, which you know, so I had nothing bad about ABBA in private
that I could think about. The only thing that stood out to >> Yet
he wouldn't talk to Kelly Jean about Dn D at all. >> Well,
actually, he did once the first conversation we had was that
Yeah. Oh >> Oh well. >> to me about these people.
They thought I was crazy that I don't lie to my >> That
I practice radical honesty with my partners. That was the only
thing everybody was like, "That's crazy." And I was like, "Yeah,
I practice radical honesty with my partner. I trust them. I trust
them like I trust myself and I'm honest with myself. But that's
the thing. People aren't honest with themselves. That's why Destiny
can get on stream and say, "Oh, I'm normal. I don't have any
problems. My life is great." Well, knowing that he's having an
affair and he has cheating allegations and he's an abusive because
we don't have good relationships with ourselves. So, of course,
you know, I'm sitting there like, "Of course, I don't lie to
my partner." That's the only conversation we ever had that made
me look at everybody with a raised eyebrow, even Abba. But every
otherwise, every interaction was great, genuinely. So, it was
a big disappointment that he couldn't walk the walk when it came
to it cuz look at the downplay. >> Feel bad. And this might
surprise you because some of you don't know this. Me and Destiny
have spoken about his dating behavior for a very long time. We've
talked about it on stream, offstream, and I've always been very
vocal about the fact that I think he's very dysfunctional with
how he handles his dating with how he prioritizes pleasure over
everything else. And I think the root of a lot of these issues
in this whole situation is that he prioritizes own selfish desires
over other people's wellbeing over >> but he's not see
how the way he's talking about it is the same way I genuinely
thought this is why I'm saying I had the same attitude. So, I
think this is probably going to come down to again Abba prioritizing
like, oh, this is such a tragedy that Destiny couldn't be better
for Destiny's sake, right? That like there there are victims
in this case. There are people who were hurt by Destiny and Abba's
commentary is largely like those people kind of suck. And it
just sucks that Destiny also sucks. Like those people suck. Like
that kind of seemed like the angle he was going at it from. And
it just feels it feels a little weird. I get it. I get why people
are like, "Oh, but he he did something." I don't know. At the
time, we were seeing a lot of nothing from most people. So, this
was a I didn't really hate this at the time, but we'll keep watching
what Britney's analysis >> When Destiny and Molina were
coming to me about their relationship that, hey, you guys are
toxic. You're not treating each other well. You got to stop doing
this to each other. And I was I was understanding the gravity
of the situation. Then I find out about Lauren before I come
to Miami. Okay? I had just learned about Lauren right before
I was about to meet everybody for the first time. And I was like,
"Oh." And then Okay. And then I didn't even know about everything
else. The fact that Abba is doing this well knowing what he did
to those girls, that's what I'm saying. What does a man have
to do for you to admit he's a p predator? What does your boy
have to do before it's too far? Okay. So, when I say that there
is a correlation between all of this high school with money and
the downplaying of the abuse, it's there. But trust me when I
say this, like most of the petty that happens on the left is
petty.
Most of the happens with these centrist liberals and conservatives
is some up. I will say out of all my lived experiences, whether
it was me having a sandwich with Abigail Thorne, which by the
way was very lovely. Abigail was actually lovely. We had a very
quick >> I don't care why >> non-personal lunch with
a group of people. Okay, she was really lovely when I met her.
Nelly was anxious and up, but she wasn't like Destiny. Okay,
Lindsay was really a mean girl, but she wasn't like Destiny as
far as I know. Okay, Danny's guy ego, but they're not Destiny.
Destiny is Destiny. He's literally a predator that he gets to
be on the internet as the guy who stands up for women. I'll show
you this in a second. Let me show you how normies view Destiny
because that's what I was >> No, he doesn't. He doesn't
get to be that guy anymore. That that is not a thing anymore.
>> A little bit when I came into the space. Let me show
you his branding on TikTok after this video. But this video is
important because there's two different views of Destiny. The
guy who fights Magga guys and red pillars and defends women and
the guy who blames Cluster Bees for all his problems. The men
who joke about how women, right? Right. Like the the like about
theirs and about their stuff, but like jokes. Remember that Destiny
is the guy who on a panel with me and Aba said he'd rather be
punched. Oh, no. He'd rather be raped by a man than punched in
the face because this man is so afraid of conflict. >> Oh
god, that's such a weird thing to >> I mean, it's even
weirder when you consider he's probably wearing Molina's butt
plug at that exact moment in time. >> Fighting. He goes
for your reputation. Do you know what I'm saying? Like Destiny
will go for your reputation. That's how he fights you. That's
why he's downplaying what he did to these girls because he didn't
physically beat them. He emotionally abused them and gaslit them
and filmed them against their consent. everyone's going to downplay
it because >> I think just to be clear um audio recordings
against their consent audio recordings without informing the
other person that there were recording devices like recording
right that's that's what this is I don't want to I just I'm the
kind of person where I'm like okay I just reset to that because
it's not like it's significantly less bad it's that when people
use something that's like slightly hyperbolic other people will
use that as a way to attack you even if it's totally invalid
even if it's to try to do that. Um,
right. So, you just need to go like I just try to be accurate.
That's all. >> Destiny doesn't get violent. Destiny gets
revenge. Destiny doesn't get violent. Right. Chad said people
think Destiny is some defender of women. Wait until I show you
guys because it shocks me to the core. My core every time I see
it. Every time I see it, I'm like, there he is. >> We have
clips. What do we have clips of? What? What? What? >> What's
the stuff Lauren keeps saying about you? >> Oh, right.
Where he denies this. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. We're Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
>> Yeah. I I know the clip. >> He's such a good guy
to women right now. You know, Chess, didn't he say he was violent
with his first ex his first wife? I think he was the victim of
that abuse situation, but I think Destiny also said that Steven
Crowder I know Destiny said that Steven Crowder wasn't abusive.
No, we can't know that. So, Destiny is abusive, but from my understanding,
I think he was the one being physically beat by his wife during
that relationship. I believe. Okay. Listen to ABBA see this video.
>> What's good for business? And that was >> I mean,
he talked about choking that person out. I don't know. Yeah.
>> See, listen to that. Listen to what he just said. Listen
what he just said. >> I think the roots of a lot of these
issues in this whole situation is that he prioritized his own
selfish desires over other people's well-being, over what's good
for his business and his career. And now it's costing him more.
It cost him already some things in the past and he's always been
very much in denial about how it affects him negatively and now
it's costing him even more. And I'm to this day not entirely
sure if he's ready to really acknowledge the impact it has on
him. >> You think I'm self-destructive? >> This is
the video clip. Abba is showing this in his video, but this is
the video clip that I reference when I say even Abba called Destiny
out on his hedenism and Destiny's like when when has Aba ever
done this? But Abba does. I just wish Abba could have followed
up and I'm waiting. I am open if not to being friends with Abba,
but I'm open to hearing. I would love to see a video from Abba
saying that Destiny is a predator. I shouldn't have watered down
the video. I should have been honest. I should have said he belongs.
Um, you know, he's dangerous to people. He's dangerous. And that's
the problem. People won't see him as dangerous. I mean, people
are still doing political events with him. And I get it if you
don't know. I really do. I empathize if you genuinely don't know.
But that's why I say from now on I'm gonna try my best to do
research and just tell people if there's anything about this
person tell me now because I did not know most of the stuff about
Destiny. You know what I >> Yeah. Yeah. If you would say
self-destructive I say something about Destiny. I think he can
be self-destructive. I don't think >> from a philosophical
perspective I also think hedonism is bad. I'm not a fan of it
and I don't agree. >> Entirely disagree. >> I completely
disagree though. Hold up. Hold up. I was actually curious. You
don't think that to some degree your hedonism doesn't you? >> No.
I think I have a really good engagement with most of my hobbies.
I think I do it pretty well. I think that my mental functioning
is very high. I think my career is incredibly successful. There
are parts of my life that I can >> pause. Actually, Chad,
you're so smart. Since Destiny doesn't want to feel superior
physically. >> Wow.
Wow.
>> He wants to feel superior mentally. That's what his
abuse looks like. When he talked to Dr. K and he told Dr. K,
"I identify solely with my mind and I can't imagine anyone identifying
with their body." That's exactly it. He wants to be the smartest
person in the conversation. So, that tells him he's right. If
he's the smartest person in the room, he must be right no matter
what he does. Remember when I said you can't trust Destiny politically
if he's abusing people behind closed doors and cheating on people?
He said, "What does my personal life have to do with my politics?"
everything. It should it should matter. >> That's why you
say stop building >> she's actually spitting right now.
Damn >> bridges with these people. And that's why I love
young progressives because young progressives aren't going to
build bridges with these people, but millennials will.
>> Millennials will, which is why I'm going to comment
about uh CJ the X and Jreg and FD Signifier. Even though I like
them, I think it's interesting their desire to want to make like
make moves. I have I have a video I'm going to show you. I'm
going to show you. It's disappointing, but I get it because they
work in politics and I don't I don't want to win at any cost.
I don't want to build bridges with abusers. I don't want to build
bridges with people who uh do this. But that's why I'm not in
politics. I'm in philosophy cuz I'm about what's true, right?
But let me explain it to you cuz I don't think they're evil for
wanting to do it. Right. Chess said, "I don't think CJ is a millennial."
Well, I don't think CJ's a millennial either. I'm pretty sure
they're Gen Z. But that's not the point, right? The when I mention
the millennials, I mean the millennials, guys. When I mention
Gen Z, I will mention Gen Z. But I >> Where was the ABBA
video dishonest? Where was Where was Abba dishonest in that video?
It seems from Abba's view it was more of the same bad behavior
and he was done with it. I think from Abba's view he was saying
like it's sad that Destiny can't prioritize himself correctly.
Like I would like to be friends with him. It's it's like ignoring
the actual pattern of behavior that this continued to reinforce
and that he'd seen most of this content through Destiny's lens
instead of somebody else's lens. Like there's there's just some
things I don't think he's being dishonest. I think he's like
broadly uninformed and he's just like, "Oh, again, bro. I literally
like supported you this Mr. Girl and we're doing it again. I'm
done. I think that's what it was. I think it's like he knows
kind of what the allegations are. Doesn't really care like whether
they're true or not. He's just like again
just mentally ill people abusing mentally ill people. It's mostly
in his DMs that were critical, right? That's that's the broad
energy I get from it. And I listen I don't even like I don't
care that much about I don't need Abba to like come out and have
a perfect understanding of this. I'm just saying if you want
to there's probably criticism there. That's all. I I meant sorry
in my head you're right in my head I was referencing just the
collab that Kyla Erdite and CJ did with FD that the collab they
did that's what I was referencing not that he or they sorry they
are Jenzi right okay sorry uh we have a few more minutes of this
video to watch because I think ABBA mentions me sub
>> the last comment
>> I'm not sure and I'm curious what you guys think I think
markers were troubled stuff on me but I think I'm living one
of the healthiest lives I possibly could >> uh you know
constantly having poor relations with women over a long period
of time or in other situ situations, STDs, different things like
that. Eventually that comes back to bite them. >> Okay
guys, we are ending on the Twitch stream. All right, thank you
for everybody for watching on Twitch. All right, we had a long
happy Twitch stream today. Thank you guys for showing up. Really
appreciate it. I think we're going to head over to kickon for
the rest of the stream. So, the 30 people watching on Twitch,
head over to kick kick.com/jc.
I'll pin that in the chat for you. All right, and we're going
to continue this coverage over there. Head over.
All right, keep watching the stream over there. Thank you for
watching on Twitch so far. Really appreciate everyone over there.
All right, guys. We'll see you over on kick shortly. Right away.
All right. Bye-bye. All right. We're on the kick only stream
now. Let's go.
Let me switch this over from multireaming. Boom. Boom. There
we go. All right. We continue, guys. We
>> And they also recognize you could have invested in that
time a lot better. >> So, wait. What do you ask us about
this? Like what was your idea of this? >> I have like 100
kids and 5 million STDs and like >> No. No. You just constantly
>> Yeah. It's not like I have 100 kids and a bunch of SDs.
says, "No, you've recorded videos of women that you've shared.
You violated consent. You had an affair with Lauren Suin." >> Oh,
Britney Simon needs to watch some uh President Sunday stuff.
There's probably a lot of reason to believe that his his like
whole conservatives, we should be empathetic with conservatives
arc was purely from his relationship with Lauren Southern, right?
As soon as he moved away from his relationship with Lauren Southern,
he immediately started going, "Oh, conservatives are evil again."
And just went hard on him. Right? So, there's every reason to
believe that he was actually changing his political opinions
because of the person he was trying to [__] >> No,
I'm not. >> Well, you might as well. No, you're going to
go for No, no, no. Say it. Say >> Y'all do. We haven't
gone over the Willy Mack thing yet. >> Yeah, we haven't
gone over it yet. >> No, shut up. Shut up. Let him talk.
What do you mean? >> Anything you do in life that's going
to increase like your ability to like have fun or do like crazy
or whatever. It's always going to carry with it like the risk
of death, right? Absolutely. Like you have no chance of dying
by falling. >> See how See how good this sounds? Like he
sounds like he's making a really good argument, right? Like remember
when we were doing the collab in Miami with all of us together
and I said, "Would you rather have Lav and Mr. Girl in your life
or Molina?" And he said, "Well, if Molina made me choose, I'd
pick I'd pick Mr. your girl and laugh because I I want the choice
to engage in the danger. Now, do I think this correlates with
his impulsive issues with ADHD? Yes. Do I think ADHD makes you
a bad person? No. I think your values do. I do not think borderline
makes you a bad person. I think your values do.
Period. Wow. >> So, yeah. Does he have impulse control
cuz he won't get it together? Yes. But it's his values that ultimately
allow him allow him to do these things. It's ultimately his values
and that's the >> of a plane unless go skydiving. That's
not an argument. It's never skydiving. >> But it is an
argument against maybe skydiving a thousand times if you want
to die. If you want to sky a thousand times a thousand times
like what's >> The religion was proper weird. The religion
was weird in retrospect where he was like totally an atheist
his entire life and he's like you know I kind of want to know
something about this. No, this seems like really you know I can
see how you know I I want to be a better person. Oh there's actually
some really good insights that CS Lewis has here guys.
>> damn what happened with all the selfment [__]
that you guys talking about >> I mean it just depends on
whether or not you want that outcome. If you're saying like,
"Oh, I don't want this kind of destructive thing. I don't want
to end up dying by maybe don't skydive every other day." >> Yeah,
but I'm not complaining about that. You guys are if your if your
if your lifestyle choices are like, "Damn, I would never want
to deal with like a crazy girl or anything like that." That's
totally valid. I think it's totally fine. I accept that that's
probably true for most people, but like I'm okay with the trade-off
on that for like all the benefit I get. I like being a lot of
people. I like traveling. I like doing drugs. I like my script.
It's super fun for me to be like, "Well, doesn't bad stuff happen
sometimes. You shouldn't do it. That doesn't compute to me."
Like I feel like I'm living a super amazing life. I feel like
there's a lot of [__] that happens all the time.
I understand it might be a lot for some people, but it seems
weird to be like, "Oh, I think that you're like secretly like
hurting or damaging." At this exact time, he was sharing
to people non-consensually, right? like over and over again.
Like he was doing this a lot at this exact time. He was like,
"I just like I like there's no downsides, guys. There's no downsides."
No, there's no no like downsides for you as long as you're not
caught. I guess
seems like you're violating a lot of consent at this period of
time, bro. Because
others think the main thing with this is you have to think about
the activity. The activity involves hurting others. Even Destiny,
as good as he is what he does, probably could admit he's broken
a lot of hearts. He's disappointed a lot of women's meal. >> I
agree. Discord YouTube chat YouTube chat says, "I'm behind. But
Destiny gives these responses to you and Aba about his life is
so robotic and rehearsed." 100%. which is why it sounds good
to people. It sounds good to people because he already has like
a comeback, but it's not. As >> long as I don't stop talking
to each other, the results are obvious. And then that's why when
he was going through the divorce with Molina and wasn't talking
about Lauren Southern, I wasn't sure if I should speak up because
I was so annoyed that he wasing the internet and Molina as some
like cheating when the reality was that behind the scenes he
was cheating with Lauren Southern. Lauren was going through a
divorce. Everything was messy and it was just like the craziest
situation in which they begged us not to tell anybody cuz they
were working on their marriage. And then by the time it came
out, I wasn't in this. I wasn't talking to anyone anymore. So
by the time their divorce happened, I was no longer in contact
with Destiny or Molina, right? >> A lot of people upset.
It's not just how he feels about it. When you involve other people
in this kind of pursuit of pleasure, other people get hurt as
well. I stand by what I said at the beginning. I don't feel bad
for Stephen whatsoever cuz he knew what he was getting into.
He was brazen about it when he was warned. When he said, "Hey,
this is a bad idea. This is a bad life. I don't care. I want
to have fun. It's fun for me. That's why I like these mentally
ill women. That's why I like doing this stuff." >> Caused
these mentally ill women. Their mental illness isn't the problem.
It's their values. And that's why I thought it was when my values
were obviously clearly so different and I did engage in certain
ways and yet I was thrown under the bus. But these women do have
value issues. But it's not the women and their mental illness
that's the problem. It's the fact that Destiny manipulated everyone
to use their mental illness against these women to prove that
he was correct. Well, he was abusing them. He
>> Yes. Oh my god. We get to the I knew she'd be spitting
at some point. I knew cuz she she has some understanding of these
things. She has some understanding of like how these things go.
Yes. Exactly. that he is going to that he's going to hook up
with people who are mentally ill and at the same time go okay
now when they get mad about my bad behavior I'm just going to
go I'm just going to go you know what actually
you have BBD I don't I don't have to take that seriously you
you're completely insane wait I what do you mean I went cold
the second you stopped sending me news I went cold all these
what do you mean that's manipulative no you're just mentally
ill what do you mean I I said I'd fix your reputation and stop
calling you a stalker no you're just mentally ill now you're
just mentally ill mentally manipulating Anna Anna Var, okay,
who I also have no interest in talking to. I blocked her early
on cuz she harassed me on the internet and I was like, "Uh-uh,
girl." And I know, I know she's going through it, but he was
her, was involved with her while telling the internet she was
stalking him. >> Do you know what I'm saying? >> And
like, I think this is such a tangled amount of web. Let me just
pull up the paint really fast, guys, to kind of move us through
this. >> I want to show you. Um, >> no way. >> What's
happening here? >> Hold on. >> Hold on. Uh, hello.
>> Hello. Okay, so I I said this the other day on stream,
but I think it's important. Okay, so there's a YouTuber like
Destiny and Contra. >> Not going to lie, it still feels
like the pot calling the kettle black. Maybe you can disabuse
me of the idea that she runs an OF cult. Um, >> of cults.
>> I would just say, >> what is that? >> I
don't know how many people have come out against her with like
uh saying she was like manipulating them for material or something
or like violating consent in some way. Like maybe you could argue
that she's just a significantly more apt predator than Destiny,
I guess. But I I've not seen the evidence that like as many people
have come out and she's just gone, you're totally mentally ill.
But maybe maybe she has. I'm not totally >> Who's whose
career goes up, but their mental health goes down. Okay, these
are the destinies and the contras. The more up they are mentally,
I swear to God their content gets better. Okay, so it's like
a comedian. Comedians are always afraid of getting therapy cuz
like maybe their comedy won't be as funny. I always said Sneo
would have been poor had he gotten the right kind of therapy.
>> I always said Sneo had the potential to really be a
good person, but he would have been poor. >> This is weird.
>> And I think that shows in a lot of leftist content.
Like we don't make a lot of money, but that's because we often
make decisions that are more moral and ethical, so we don't get
the bag. Period. ABBA and Preach make so much money being misogynists
and homophobes and transphobes. Okay? Yes, they spend their time
ragging on the red pill, but they're still not much different.
You know, they're the I you know, they're like the red pillars
are like no consent
>> I think I I would like to see any evidence at all that
ABBA has like the values that like consent is not valuable. I
think like the values are probably good there. His inability
or his like bias and not seeing them in his friend is obvious
as well, but I don't I don't have a lot of indication that him
as a person that he's like at least from what Britney said, right?
like Britney went and uh spent time with Aba in an Airbnb and
said [__] is like really considerate that's like
your personal experience and everything but the fact that he
didn't really hardcore denounce destiny is kind of pointing you
the direction that he's like a certain way that's like somewhat
respectful and not like super hateful and and probably somebody
you could deal with and then there's the one thing which is his
refusal or inability to disavow Destiny. I would say it's more
likely to me that that's the aberant behavior, his inability
to disavow Destiny rather than all the other stuff. That's probably
how I'd look at it, right? So, probably there's something biasing
him there. Probably that this is like one of the few friends
he'd made from YouTube, few like long-term friends he'd made
from YouTube and it felt like there's just a lot of feelings
there. I I don't know why this wouldn't be humans going to human,
right? I feel like that's a classic example of humans going to
human. I think
>> I'm just going to kiss a girl if I want. AB and preacher
are like, "You should ask if you should kiss her." And I'm saying,
"You should also before you kiss her, make sure she has informed
consent." And they're like, "Too much work." And I'm like, "Okay,
it's like they're better than my work, >> but they're not
like >> too much work." >> Better than FD. Do you
know what I'm saying? They're not better than all these other
men who are deconstructing. And I give FD a lot of credit, even
though he's a straight man because he seems to be more into um
valuing people who are trans and who are, you know, gay and who
are progressive and all these other things, which I appreciate.
Right. Okay. So, YouTubers who's >> I I'll be honest. I
I don't I can't remember what Aba said to me. He probably did
say some things, but I don't know what it was.
>> Goes what did he say? You don't remember? Oh, okay.
>> As their mental health, okay, >> but at the same
time as their careers are going up. >> Uh if somebody has
a clip and you want to show it, you guys could pull it up, but
I don't have a clip >> and going down. Their real lives
are in turmoil, right? So like they are not having a relationship
with self. and the relationship with self is impacting let me
put in different colors uh oops sorry is impact girl is impacting
their career okay and their personal life and then on top of
that they've got layers of the world is up everything is horrible
what do we do oh my gosh and then on top of that it's like oh
now you're responsible now do something about it and it's like
oh my gosh and then it's like oh by the way also you have kids
and siblings and responsibilities and family members and it's
like oh my god and then oh my gosh the economy have I brought
up the economy yet it's like and then you have a Contra who loses
it on Reddit. Freaks out on Twitter. You have a destiny. >> By
the way, if you guys are just tuning in now, if you guys are
just tuning in now, she is referring to Contra Points and her
Israel Palestine thing as like a reason that Contra Points is
like not doing well and there's like she she's got like a lot
of hate for Contra Points and she thinks Contra Points is she
kind of asserted Contra Points was being a bigot with her Israel
Palestine post which I thought was insane. But >> work
and abandon my kid. You have Eli. >> Here's the thing.
Um and I don't want people to make this mistake. Contra Points
is almost certainly very informed on this conflict, right? Like
they've been very interested in politics. They've been a like
top tier political creator for a long time. They almost certainly
have a very informed take on this. A lot of the criticisms that
you make of like a lot of other media personalities around this
is going to revolve around their total inability to engage with
the content critically, the the political concepts critically,
right? That's probably not the case for Conquer Points. I don't
think this is the same as like if you're looking at like a Willie
Mack comment or something like that, right? It's just not the
same at all. So, I think there's probably
some argument that
uh I don't know. I like kind of understand what Britney's doing,
but I yeah, I don't think you go after Contra in the same way
that you can go after a lot of the other people who are super
uninformed, the Mudahars, even like the Hassans or something
>> and Trump having their fight in public with the nuclear
codes. We have like all of these things are happening and I'm
saying everybody breathe. >> How the would Britney know
what's going on in Contra Point's personal life? I think she's
she's been a YouTuber for a long time and like a like a well-known
well-letworked YouTuber for a long time. She might know Contra
Points. She's been at dinners at lunches or something with Contra
Points. She told a personal story a little while earlier, so
she she might know her like somewhat. Probably not really well.
>> Tackle each line one at a time or some in conjunction
until it starts to become a clear image. Breathe. Breathe. Breathe.
Breathe. Breathe. Breathe. Breathe. until it gets to the point
where nothing's
>> you good
at you. >> This is very annoying. >> Who are you
in relation to the world and in relation to yourself? What do
you believe? What do you stand for? What do you want for the
world? And how do you show up in the world in a way that coincides
with those values? Breathe. I know it's a lot. I know it's a
lot. I'm not going to ask you to be perfect, girlies, but I am
going to point out when we're definitely being imperfect.
Okay. So, when I call out ABBA or anybody else, I don't I'm not
calling out you as a human. I'm calling out the person that is
presented in your YouTube channel. And I understand if you guys
want to hold me to the fire as well, do it, right? Like be like
Britney, but you said this here. Listen, if my content is 6 months
old, it's probably out of date, but you need to do that, right?
Pat says, "Well, I understand this. I think it's more to do with
where your motivation is. I always say these things. Some people
are motivated by the idea of success and the other people the
fear of failing." For sure. Yeah. Like, everyone's motivated
by completely different things. And I think it's really important
that we figure it out. Like I know my motivation as an example.
I come to my work with a very specific idea in mind, right? I
believe we're evolved animals on the planet, right? Like I believe
we're evolved animals on a planet. I expect very little from
people. I think we give ourselves too much credit. But the little
that I expect isn't really about giving ultimatums. It's about
doing what I'm going to do. You keep doing what you're going
to do. I'm going to do what I'm going to do. But what matters
to me is what I do. Not really what you do. I don't care what
you do. I care what I do. And I think all of us should be caring
about what we do. Cuz right now what we are is we're destinies.
Destiny will say
she's she's talking. She's talking a >> Well, if you're
going to be like this, then I'm going to be like this. Holy.
>> And I said, "No, no matter how they are, you have to
be better." The vanguards, who I don't like to watch, go, "Well,
if >> minutes in, you're all dog piling on
>> Okay, this is Hold on, hold on, hold on. Where am I?
I didn't want her to die. Destiny and ABBA press Kelly Jean.
>> Wait, who is this about? That would be >> Wait,
where do I pile? >> Where do I dogpile on Kelly Jean? What?
>> Also, did I mean to join this? I don't think I say anything.
I'm probably there. Oh, I do say something. Hold on. I am muted
to say something. There's definitely one of these early calls
where I joined like after getting perms. I didn't even mean to.
And uh I sat there silently for a long time. >> The Republicans
are going to be like this. The Democrats should be like this.
>> And I know you're thinking, "Oh, you want to play nice
with Republicans?" I don't even think you should be talking to
Republicans. >> You're not going to play it. >> Your
neighbor. >> No, I'm saying give me a time stamp. Think
15 minutes in. Yeah. Is 15 minutes the exact time stamp? Okay,
hold on. 15 minutes. I apparently talk about
>> Oh, I'm making fun of Mark. Whoops.
15 minutes in. I'm apparently dog piling Kelly. Hold on.
>> Oh, shut up. There were enough people interrupting each
other without me like
Anyway. Um, why you keep going around saying I'm a misogynist?
You >> Oh, me? >> Yes, you. >> Cuz you're attacking
every single woman in here with >> every single woman
>> I think she's literally defending Merc at this point.
>> I was 100%.
>> I feel like Kelly, if another woman's shining, she feels
the need to come in here. That's why she's up at 5 in the morning
with red eyes. >> It's 3:30. Okay. >> It's actually
just women of color she has a problem with. >> And True.
>> True. Black women special
edition. >> That's so gay. That's so gay. >> Actually
go. >> That guy's a complete nutter fs slur. The guy who
just piped up right there. That's a complete nutter fs slur right
>> What a weak spineless
constantly [__] dumpstering on her the entire time.
All right, let's go with that. >> Imagine doing now and
you're a woman. You are a woman who goes through the same exact
thing exact things. >> I was I was just angry at Merc.
Murk was being so I was so annoyed with Merc with the things
she was saying, right? And I took it out on Kelly. >> It
doesn't.
>> All that is fake by the way. She is trying to protect
Murk in this game. >> You really shouldn't be here if it
>> That's right. M. Kelly. Kelly. Kelly is like crabs in
the bucket. But like in the bucket, >> right? Cuz M is
the one I should be most concerned about. If you mean like she
>> Oh, you mean Merk's not even a threat to you? She's
so insignificant. >> This is people just poking Kelly Jean.
That's not That's not an honest conversation. That's people just
poking >> Okay. But I want to hear what else Abba has to
say cuz that was the point of listening to it. Right. I don't
remember watching. Yeah, but I don't think it's just that you're
getting dogpiled. That's all. That was the whole video. >> Yeah,
but I don't remember what he said. >> They haven't watched
anymore. I can give you the link if you want. Hold on. Such >> such
an ass. They're They're literally saying they haven't watched
more. They don't know more. I'm not watching this whole video
right now. Yeah. Okay. I'm not watching that whole video right
now. >> Republican politician. >> That's way of left
field. Kelly, >> I don't want to build bridges with them.
But as long as you fight with them, you're building a bridge.
>> That was where the time stamp was. >> But yeah,
you keep doing you. >> That's why I can't keep my my pants
because it's fun. Well, then when it blows up in your face, I'm
not going to have no sympathy for you. Be my friend, my worst
enemy. I don't give a if you engage in behavior repeatedly after
you're warned around and find out. And that's what Steven is
doing. But I don't want to make it just sound like a happy dance
and a heisenism that no, some of this stuff is also just morally
bad in regards to what he did with recording these women and
all this other [__] And he if he gets sued for it,
he loses money, then it is what it is, too. >> See? DC
see. Yeah, he was like morally bad. He should have done it. If
he gets sued, it is what it is. Your friend is like Diddy, bro,
but less. Your friend is a light Diddy and you're acting like
it's just like he Oh, what? That's what I'm saying. Listen to
the way he's talking about it. Like, your friend is literally
a serial predator. What are you talking about? Why are you downplaying
it like that? In what world can we ever record people against
their consent and share it? In what world could we even take
a recorded video of somebody and share it? >> You do the
crime, you do the time, right? So, no. All these people be like,
"Oh, I have a sick body. your friend. I already told y'all if
my friend goes out and murders a bunch of people, I'm going to go
send his to jail. And if my friend does some like what Stephen
just did and he's going to lose a bunch of money, I'm not going
to cry. I would tell my friends and I would warn them beforehand,
hey, don't do that. Don't do that. You go and do it. Hey man,
that's your problem. >> See, I don't think you warned him.
Don't do that. Don't do that. See, this is Oh, Britney's going
to notice what this is, right? Listen, this is from a hyper critical
lens. I I wouldn't watch this video and give Abba because I don't
think Abba would respect commentary from this lens anyway. It
just would be a waste of time for me to deliver this commentary
and like criticism towards him. But she's probably gonna say
something like, "I told you not to do that. Not to do that."
That is Abbott giving away that he thinks what happened here
was Destiny kept interacting with mentally ill people and then
some happened that would always happen with mentally ill people,
right? Like that's >> when you say,
"Sorry."
>> Well, that's that's what I think Abba feels like is
happening here. When he says, "Oh, I told him not to do that.
I told you not to do that." And you get up for doing that. It's
like the real crime is interacting with mentally ill people or
something, which is like a up way to look at this, right? Uh,
I think that's what Britney's gonna say. Kelly, you want to respond
to that? >> Yeah. When you say through this lens, what
do you mean? Sorry. What is the >> I just hyperritically
like I I just wouldn't I wouldn't even be looking for that level
of like kind of >> under the surface thing a lot of the
time unless I'd been critical of ABBA for a while, watched like
a lot of his content. But I do think that's sort of revealing
that that's probably what he really and I think that comes out
in other places in the video, right? I think that comes out in
other places in the video that that's probably like what he thinks
Steven really did wrong was interacting with these people. He's
like, "I made this criticism. I told him that your messy personal
relationships would lead to this or something." >> And
it kind of it kind of leans in a >> I don't think would
ever Well, I don't think would ever really look at like evidence
and say, "No, no, no, this is totally fake." I think he it's
like the way I assume he thinks is I'll try to assume his point
of view is oh um that allegations come come out. Um at best
it's him being interact interacting with people who are going
to do this to him. At best, that's the best possible scenario
for him. And even if that's the case, I'm going to cut ties,
right? And that's sort of the how he talks about it. But what
he what he would do is like I'm sure if if somehow like he was
implicated or he had to like actually analyze the evidence, I'm
sure he'd say, "Oh, this is really disgusting." And not blame
people. But I think he's like, "Oh, even even at a surface level,
this is too much. I'm out. I told this guy to stop around like
this. Bye." But it it can come off as dismissive and underplaying.
And yeah, anyway, I think that's so if if I was looking at it
through his lens, that's probably how he feels about it, right?
I'm disconnecting anyway. I'm never going to be around this guy
ever again anyway. So, I don't even need to analyze further.
>> It's just a bit annoying because mentally ill people
are more likely to be victimized, but like that type of mentality
just kind of makes them less important as a victim. It's kind
of
>> Just said I'm on team Britney. I spent the first like
hour and a half of this conversation explaining why Britney was
wrong on how she was recounting things from the past. I don't
know. I don't know what more I got to do, bro. >> It's
like this idea of Yeah, he's too casual. Thank you, Chad. He's
way too casual about it. And that's the disappointment. When
are we going to stop being casual about pred predatory behavior?
Like, when are we going to stop being casual about it? And no
wonder Trump got elected. No wonder people voted for cuz we are
way too casual with abuse towards women or abuse is abuse at
all. We're way too casual about it. >> Bro, you didn't
listen to me. You're not going to get my sympathy at this point.
Nope. My sympathy for when a tragedy happens, not when inevitable
does. Yeah. What you're hearing from me right now is disappointment
and a bit of anger. But I'm angry at myself. Sir, you know, if
there's anything that this situation and that most of the people
in these online spaces have taught me is that these are not serious
people. Um, the problems are not serious. The way they engage
with relationships is not serious. >> I did not hear what
she just said, um, Desi got Trump elected. I think, listen, that
firefighter
went out a long way. I think that had real effects on people.
I can't speculate. Just like with the the Palestine thing, I
can't really speculate. Um, that that's not what she said. Well,
I'm just responding to Stephen Jellyian then because I wasn't
listening to her. that that firefighter
I'm telling you that is like uh that went hyper wide. That was
a big thing
that that would have and that would have pushed the people to
go like uh this kind of gross. But I'm not going to I'm not going
to make the argument it lost the election. I'm just saying it's
pretty consequential in my opinion. Like I think easily, here's
the argument I would make. Easily
that could have undone a lot of the canvasing stuff. Easily in
terms of aggregate national vote or something, right? I think
so. I'm not even saying it's like morally wrong to do that. Soap
box. That's the thing. I'm not saying it's like morally wrong.
I'm saying that you do you have like an unhinged take like that
that can push people in another direction that got Trump elected.
No, I'm not saying that got Trump. I just said I was not going
to say that. I'm saying that that's probably like consequential.
Like that might have been his most consequential contribution
to that election is that tweet. Do you think that's a crazy thing
to say? That that would have been his most uh his most consequential
contribution to that election? I don't think that's insane to
>> Realistically, probably all of this is operating at
way too low level to have had any effect on the election at all.
But anyway, >> there's a lot of juvenile, you know, >> I
disagree that it's in this space. I think it's everywhere. I
think it's in politics. I think ABBA's a part of it. I'm a part
of it. And I think that's why we have to be on the healthier
side of it. I think adulthood period is high school with money.
Even the adults in my life who think they're so mature and so
the elder in the community are still voting for Trump, are still
making fun of trans people with blue hair, are still pro-Russia,
are still 50 years old dating 25-year-olds. You all want to pretend
you're the adults in the room. Then why are you dating children?
Like, let's be so for real. You're the adult in the room, but
you're acting like a little [__] when things don't
go right. >> That's like a shot at somebody very specific
in Britney's life, right? What is she? 50 50 years old dating
somebody 25. I feel like that's like her like uncle or her father
or something. I feel like I feel like that's her taking a shot
at somebody very specific in her >> Like no, we're not
the adults in the room. We're certainly not working on it. >> That's
funny. >> We have to be. And I don't think Aba is anymore
the adult in the room. As much as you want to give him some credit
for being, I think he's still got a lot to deconstruct. And that's
why I say I'm not there either. I know for a fact that I am not
the adult in the room yet. I'm an adult. You know, I go to work.
I pay my bills. But I really want to get to the point where like
when I get to 40, that's my goal. >> Not in the room >> with
the other adults. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. >> Because
you know, a lot of autistic people, we're really late bloomers.
I'm trying to be there. Okay. So, you can throw me under the
bus, too. >> But that's the problem. It's like we are high
school with money, right? >> While I was on vacation, I
was just hearing glimmers about this stuff. I'm just turn that
[__] off cuz I'm honestly if you touch grass and
you hear this stuff, you're like, "Y'all some losers." You realize
like this is a story about >> again, y'all some losers.
It's like, bro, I'm he just I don't know if he just didn't have
he probably just didn't have all the facts at this time, right?
Cuz to me, I hear him like >> it's like bolted on allegation
that he did this to Pixie. Like it's just it's actually just
proven already, right? You're like, "Oh, you are losers." That's
just a weird It's a weird reaction to have. But again, he's probably
most dog or something. I don't know. You'd have to ask him. >> How
did you not hear me?
You suck. Anyway, why is this guy pretending like he wasn't in
the zoo with us? He literally had an offline NVC argument with
me. Like, you're a loser, too. Like, nobody who's not loser does
that. >> That was my That was my comment when I watched
this video the first time. Why you pretending you weren't in
the zoo, bro? This is like a This is like a Oh, god. I got to
pick I got to pick the right Oh, I had the same I was going to
say something, but I got to pick the right zoo animal. Okay,
this is like a lion sitting outside of the cage looking in eating
popcorn going like, "Can you believe these animals?"
Like, brother, >> those like that. >> Brother, you're
you're a lion.
Brother,
>> brother, you're a lion. No, I So, the what's the most
likely thing to escape is something that can like climb and jump
and stuff would be my thoughts. And it's like I it's like, oh,
that sounds wrong. So, I'm going to go to pick something from
Africa, right? Please
>> I I literally was like, oh, I should find something
that's like there's no racial connotation. I was like, a lion.
Oh, it's from Africa.
you really ill people all engaging in behaviors and and they're
not ready for it, you know. But I also I also have to have some
humility and admit that I've tethered myself to that.
>> It's like Artful thinking he's not in the zoo with the
rest of us. Artful is a part of the zoo. Artful is like the most
articulate animal at the zoo. Okay. He is like he's he's identified.
Okay. He's like a dolphin. Actually, there's dolphins at the
zoo. Arul is like a dolphin. Okay. He's got the intelligence.
He's more intelligent than than any of the other animals, but
he is still at the zoo. All right. He's there with the rest of
us. He's like close to being enlightened. He's close to, but
he's he's still at the zoo. Absolutely. >> I dip my toes
into it. And you know, having spent some time there, was it been
entertaining? Sure. But it was entertained like it was when you
go to the zoo and you see a bunch of free >> See, see how
he's separating himself from it. I get the need to do that. I
want to separate myself from it as well. But the truth is, I
did it again. I got involved in a community online and I feel
like I could have avoided it if I did my research. >> Did
it again. >> And I think it's wrong to think that I was
above it. I just think that I was the healthier version. But
I think I got to be better at picking and choosing my collabs,
bros. I got to start being better, including collabing with Abba,
including collabing with Nico or any of these other people that
I was trying to like quote build bridges with. Collabing with
Kyla. See, here's the thing. That's what I'm saying. I don't
even think it's healthy or good to collab with Kyla. So, when
I saw CJ the X and FD do it, it was like, why are we building
a bridge with
>> Because she is still pro Destiny. So, why are we building
a bridge with her? And that's what I'm saying. I think in politics
you have to build bridges with people, but I'm not in politics,
so I don't have to do. Okay. >> Wait, I don't think she's
blaming. I don't think this is So Britney does fail to take accountability
a lot of the time, Sophia. But I don't think this is it right
here. This isn't her failing to take accountability. This is
her taking accountability, saying, "I need to be better. I need
to be better and not build bridges with people who I don't share
values with." I think this is actually her taking accountability
for most of her actions as opposed to a lot of the other video,
a lot of the rest of the video. >> And that's why Contra
people off because she keeps wanting to build bridges with people
and the rest of us are like, "No, don't do that." And everyone's
like, "You're too spoiled. You want a perfect outcome. You want
people to be perfect before you collab with them. It's like,
no. You don't think there was a world where you pull these people
in your direction? You don't think there was a world where you
pull these people in your direction? Well, look, I don't know
what that means by it, but ABBA reached out to me first. I knew
him first before I knew Destiny. Sneaker reached out to me first
cuz I made contact content about them. So, yeah, sure. Justin
Waller DM'd me cuz I made a video about him. Sure. Like, you
know, Destiny, I reached out to him because of viewer recommended
and I said, "Sure." So, I did reach out to him. But, yeah, I
make content about these people. I make content about Ethan.
I'm sure Ethan's people know who I am. No doubt. If they know
who Papa Gut is, they know who I am. They just don't like me,
which is good, but they don't like me enough to go for me. So,
I have a theory that nobody ever fights with me or makes videos
about me because honestly, I really do think I'm the healthiest
person. Not ever. There FD is healthy. Michael Burns is healthy.
Like, a lot of people are healthy. But, um, >> she's totally
Listen, it's probably not quite the Yeah. Okay. Sorry. I got
people going there for a sec. think that I talk about this content
enough in a way that keeps me away from being in the nonsense,
you know, >> but I of course I'm going to make myself aware
to them, but it's my job not to answer the DMs. Like, it's my
job not to do that. Right. Right. Jazz says, "I think they mean
if you build a bridge, you'd influence them, but I'm not sure."
Oh, are you saying Are you saying like you want to I'm sorry,
I misunderstood.
Um I'm not sure that would work on anything. You're saying if
you bring them in Yeah. Chad says, "Was Justin Waller the guy
who asked you not to bring up his associations?" Yeah. So Justin
Waller was like, "Hey, I want to do a video with you, but you
can't bring up my relationship with Andrew Tate." And I was like,
"Nah." Like I don't know about that, bro. I was like, "Sure.
Yeah, maybe." Um, yeah. I'm surprised Ethan Ken hasn't come for
you. I think I don't think I can. >> I genuinely a part
of these like I don't want them to, but I don't know what they
were being mad about. Like I >> She really She really does
have a way of not saying very much. So >> really hard just
to like be very matter of my belieassy. I I think I wanted everyone
to get better. I wanted to get better. I just don't think anyone
has to do the emotional labor. Do you know what I mean? I think
people keeping us like we do emotionally for later. Go. >> I'm
just I'm just starting to skip forward because I want to get
back to the video
on it. Going for something, go to therapy, but listen to this.
>> And now that it's gotten to the point where it's kind
of spilling over into real life and you're realizing that these
people behind closed doors are doing weird. It's time to take
a step back and be like, "Okay, we've had our fun at the zoo.
It's closing up. Time to head home. I'm not interested in being
part of the act. I'm not interested." >> Me neither. Right.
>> Good. I'm glad he's not. I'm glad. >> It's just
like when you go to the zoo and you see a monkey like another
monkey and the monkey that's getting is like trying to tragically
like craw claw away. Okay. I was like, "You know what, guys?
We're going to go home. Animal Kingdom's wild. Animal Kingdom
is >> He distanced himself. I wish it was for a better
reason, though. >> In the enclosure, I'm not interested
in befriending any of the other freak animals that they want
to bring in. It's just a weird assortment of people, and it's
just so it's so different than my real life. Like, why am I wasting
time with them? >> Sorry. I listen, we're on a onetrack
mindset recently. We'll we'll we'll switch it up. We'll start
switching it >> This is not beneficial for my personal
life. I'm not learning. >> See, he says it's not beneficial
for my business or my personal life. So, he's not disowning Destiny
because Destiny is a predator. He's disowning him because it's
not beneficial anymore. But had it stayed beneficial.
>> Wait, the consent violation there is on behalf of the
monkeys. That puts one of them as being like a white half his
Hispanic person. Okay. >> Would he have burned? What are
you talking about? >> Anything about social interaction.
So, I have nothing to gain by being around this. And despite
this being my friend, there's a lot of things that I just don't
agree with that I don't want to be associated with. Um to to
keep a long story short for those of you asking like, "All right,
what are you going to do for this conversation I had with Stephen
already? I just told him I wouldn't show up on any of his stuff
in the future. I don't think that's that big of a deal because
at the end he's going to be doing mostly political stuff from
now on. So, it's probably for the best. Um, but I just want to
be associated with it. And there's a few different reasons. I'm
going to try to go with it and I'll kind of just break down everything,
but there's a couple things I got to get out the way. Listen,
I might be the only person in this orbit who hasn't one of these
women, including Destiny herself. Um, I'm not friends with any
of these people. I don't talk to them really offline. So, I kind
of just keep my distance and that's excuse me content creators.
I don't >> I have also noted any of the women
>> Oh, I thought you were going to say I thought you were
going to say you talked uh offline. >> So, you don't see
us doing too many collaborations. I don't hang out with these
people. This whole idea that I wouldn't criticize Destiny, I
think that's also nonsense. If you spend any time watching debates
between me and him, we argue, we yell, we get very animated,
we just strongly. Yes, but when I DM'd you, you said nothing
Destiny is doing is enough and you don't agree with me that it's
bad enough. And that's the part where I'm like, our values are
different. So Abbott can say he's different than Destiny and
all this other stuff. And though I get it, but after that point,
when was it enough? Like what could Destiny do that's enough
for him? And I get that, you know, Abba was very critical of
me being nice to Sneo, but to me, Sneo and Destiny are the same.
They're literally the same to me. So, I always thought it was
interesting that Aba was so critical of me being kind to Sneo,
even though I dropped Sneo, the moment two women came out, right?
The moment two girls came out, I was out. But the fact that girls
kept coming out about Steven and his destruction in different
ways, not as bad as we, you know, it got, but that wasn't enough.
>> And there's dozens of debates to do that wouldn't take
a stand if I saw something I didn't like. I think people can't
understand why I'd be friends with him or they can't understand
why I would agree with anything he says. And so, the only thing
in their head is like, "Okay, let's be friendship, whatever."
I don't operate that way. If I disagree with you, preach is my
brother and I disagree with him every day. So, if you don't think
I'm not going to disagree with this you bug it, okay? And there's
a lot of content creators who, you know, we thought they thought
he was cool and I just grew something they said now they don't want
to talk no more. So, >> is he talking about me? That's
what I
>> See, the problem is is you could say, "Oh, is he talking
about me here?" Right? You could say this, but then unfortunately
there are a bunch of people who are going to go, "Oh, you're
crazy, Britney." You could do it, but it's like he all you'd
have to do is go, "Oh, no. I'm not talking about you."
Like, it's just best to be like, "Oh, I don't know how to analyze
that." It's like it's you're damned if you do, damned if you
don't. There ABBA could easily be talking about her by the way.
But is you're just going to give the incel people who have no
ability to argue or make points or articulate themselves. You're
just going to give them the ability to go, "Well, it's all about
you, isn't it? Oh, it's all about you, I guess." Right? Um I
will always give you the charity there in that situation, but
I'm just telling you like optically probably doesn't work in
your favor, right? >> But I I'll I'll always just analyze
it. But um for for Britney, it's like, "Oh well, it's all about
you, isn't it?" And people who can't form an argument, can't
engage, don't understand, can barely speak English, can barely
actually breathe, like they they're so that their autonomic nervous
system is like shutting down. Okay. Those people will just be
like, "It's all about you, isn't it? You're kind of crazy, aren't
you?" >> Yeah. Yeah. >> The autonomic I watch, are
you talking >> Also, I wanted to say >> because he
was shocked that >> Yeah. They will fail to breathe because
their automated functions will shut >> I was going to say,
just to clarify, I was making >> You don't have to clarify
anything. You don't have to clarify anything. Thank >> I
said I didn't sleep with the women. It that was the joke and
then I said alas because I'm God damn it. Just in case anyone
didn't tell me why. And then I don't know if that's true. I don't
know if he's talking about me, but I was like yeah, I want him
to be shocked if that's the case. I think he should wonder like
I can't believe Britney doesn't want to talk to me just because
I'm staying in contact with Destiny. But that's what I want people
to get. Like do you know why though? Right. That's what I want
people to understand. I don't know though. Maybe not. Okay. So
then Abba gets diagnosed with ADHD and makes a video titled I
was wrong. It has a thumbnail of destiny in it. Right. And that
that pissed me off too cuz I'm like you're doing it again, dude.
You're downplaying his predatory behavior. So >> this is
called a retrospect. >> Okay, so we're not going to watch
his video. I just want to reference the pinned comment. So he
makes a video called I was wrong dot dot dot and he has a picture
of Destiny in the thumbnail. And I'm like why would you do that?
And it's >> he click baited it. He click baited it. >> He's
saying he got diagnosed with ADHD which cool, right? The pinned
comment says Abba and Destiny bridge being rebuilt.
He says no. Oh, lol. This will never happen. I get that is something
some viewers desire, but it's not happening. Um, he said, um,
[__] FD signifier. Any black man who spends a great
deal a great deal of time gatekeeping blackness can kick rocks.
I guess people thought that because I was not involved in destiny
that I'd be willing to suck off a bunch of socialists like Hassan
or FD. None of my politics has changed. So, it's a hard pass
for me. Okay. Okay. So, are we clear? With a continued disappointment
and misunderstanding. Look, I don't love Hassan. Okay. But it's
funny that he's mad if D will gatekeep uh blackness, but he's
not mad that they're bothering to gatekeep womanness in their
content. Anyways, so fine, his his beliefs. So now ABBA's done,
right? He's not going to he's not interested in being progressive.
He's not even interested in thinking about it. And by the way,
I don't even identify as a socialist. I don't identify with systems.
>> I think that's weird, but that's because my life doesn't
revolve around politics, even though I'm political. I vote, I
clean up, I protest, I do whatever in different ways. Like, I've
done so much throughout my life, but I don't identified really
as a capitalist. I don't identify with like systems. I just want
to be a good person. Okay. So, like you can be a good person
and support progressive values, but if you think being a progressive
means you're socialist instead of being a progressive means liberation
for all, that's the problem.
Okay.
I want liberation for all. That's what I look. That's what I
want. Who's going to give me that? Right. Okay. Now,
this relates and overlaps and again to everything happening with
Contra. Let me bring up Contra really fast so we can talk about
FD and CJ the X cuz I think it all relates. This is so fun for
me guys. Thank you for being here. I really love doing this and
I wish everybody the best. Um, but you know, this is why I'm
critical of people because I think people aren't as healed or
deconstructed as they think they are. They just like to call
themselves like a leftist or get positioned as one, right? Chess
says Aba's always been a red pill conservative. Have you all
seen his videos all these years? Yes, we know Habibi. I don't
know why you're yelling at us. We never thought he wasn't. We
were just hoping he would eventually be more left. >> Much
more of this. I don't think I'm going to watch a whole lot more.
It seems like we're basically done. Uh, let's see here.
That's going to the contra thing again. Yeah, she gets on to
the contra thing. I think we're basically done with this. I think
this is about the time. Two minutes. Two hours. 5 minutes, I
think, is the time stamp. So, we're two hours six. I think we're
basically done. AB is not conservative. I don't know. I don't
care. I really don't. I don't care at all.
All right. I don't know what I'm going to go to next. Actually,
there's so many there's there's a couple things. There's the
Candace Owens Nick Fuentes interview, which is very good, or
sorry, which I think will be very good. All right. There is the
the Techone video or the Willy Mack coverage, which the Willy
Mack coverage is going to go through the tweets and explain why
he's a complete. Right. So, I'm not totally sure what I want
to do.
Watch Nick Teone and Willie. Uh, I should do the Willie stuff
really quickly and then uh I'll go on to the Candace Owens Nick
Fentes thing probably. >> I can do I I'll do the Tech stuff
pretty
>> You're out of here. >> I was going to say you
don't want me to uh what's the word? If you want me to be I don't
know how to explain it
less combative. I could just listen to cuz I don't know what
the Willie Mac stuff is
>> Oh, it's just about how he's like a complete and totally
disingenuous, completely sidescot total [__] >> Yeah,
I just don't know what's happened the last few days or anything,
so I'm down to just listen. >> Oh, sure. Yeah, sure. Okay.
All right, cool. I was like, we will just walk through it. Uh
Willie made this tweet today about the denims thing. It's a sewing
about denims again. Why is denims posing with Nazi leaders to
promote her only fans? Hassan really letting his fellow leftists
get this desperate. I mean, for one is transparently sides sidescoop.
Okay, you're totally disingenuous. She's posing with a picture
from her lawsuit to fund raise to not be made destitute by that
exact lawsuit. Right. That is what she is doing in a vacuum.
And when you try to disconnect it, oh, she's just posting with
then why didn't she pick a better picture of this is and yes,
this is with a cues got it exactly because that's my tweet in
follow-up to this. Okay, this is obviously the most absurd and
notable page of the lawsuit. It is just a page that's talking
about how about Al Husseini and a quote from Al Husini and it's
got pictures of him with two Nazis, right? Hey, better pick of
No, I'm saying like a high resolution picture of so it would
be obvious who it was. It's not even necessarily totally obvious
who this is unless you like zoom all the way in, right? Like
you basically have to know who it is. It's like him zooming in
to get like this picture to say it's like right. So for one,
at a base level, Denim's making fun of Ethan for being a totally
histrionic is funny. Okay. Oh, you're going to you're going to
use this comparison. Sorry. You're going to use in here. You're
going to invoke to say Hassan is like Al Husini. Even though
in the lawsuit itself, you don't claim that Hassan's worked with
any Nazis, but you're going to show Al Husseini working with
some Nazis. It's just transparently like super poorly argued.
There's no reason to include these pictures. They already have
the Wikipedia citation to Al Husseini, right? It's it's like
at a base level, it's already dumb to include Al Husseini and
compare Hassan to him, but it's even more dumb to include the
pictures of Al Husseini with Okay,
none of that has to be brought up. You can mention Hassan. No,
no, no. You can mention Hassan and say Denims doesn't like me
because she's related to this Hassan person. You can establish
that if you want, but the the Al Husini thing is so stupid. It's
so embarrassing to have brought this up. And it's funny that
Denims makes fun of them for that. Okay, totally disingenuous
invocation of Nazis. And that's funny. Is she wearing shoes?
I think she has a busted heel or something, which is apparently
funny to some people. And Connor X8, this is Auggie's roommate
right here. Um, he points out, "To be fair, it's pretty obviously
meant to show the absurdity of Ethan Klein, including that in
a lawsuit about copyright infringement." True. Oh, w this guy.
This guy's always got the right opinions, by the way. Well, from
what I've seen. Okay. When I see this guy talk, I'm like, "Oh,
that guy actually pays attention." So, by arguing that it's absurd
he's showing it. You're making the argument for her. Why the
is it included in this lawsuit? Will he responds, "If you read
the lawsuit, it seems pretty obvious that it's there to show
Ethan's arguments and the reason why Snark and Denims hate him
so much. If you think her posing an only fans promotion uh with
her posing an only fans promotion pick with is a W, that can
certainly be your opinion. So again, totally disingenuous, totally
fake engagement, total
absolutely doesn't. And by the way, he set something up here.
If you read the lawsuit, that implies one that he can read, which
is a totally disingenuous lie, and two that he read the lawsuit
itself, which is another totally disingenuous lie because he
would never embarrass himself by making this point if he was
actually trying to uh argue against Adams doing this, right?
He'd never make this point. Okay. Uh, does Connor reply to this
at all? No, Connor doesn't reply more, but like it's just totally
disingenuous, right? And he argues, well, actually, we um No,
if you read the lawsuit, it like makes sense why it's included
in context,
except we read the context on stream. It's totally weird. It's
totally out of place. It doesn't make any sense. I'll show you
the context right now. We can just go to the context.
Uh, hold on. Actually, first I'll I'll show my tweet here really
quickly. Oh, I forgot I I actually took the time to like Photoshop
this. Yeah, guys. Why in the world would denims use the most
easily recognizable and most unhinged page in the entire lawsuit
to pose with? Look, this just hit this hits just as hard as the
original. And it's like this one with like some text from the
lawsuit. Obviously, it doesn't. Obviously, nobody knows what
that text is. Obviously, nobody understands what's going on.
Bad Photoshop. Yeah, it took me like 2 seconds. Yes. Obviously,
this doesn't mean anything. She wants it to be consequential.
She's trying to use the outrage from her lawsuit to fund raise
so she's not made financially destitute by that same lawsuit.
Uh I think it's pinned up there. Yeah, it's a the pin tweet in
chat there. Queen with a Q. Okay. All right. And he responds,
"She's not gonna you, bro. You don't have to defend it." Which
is okay. I guess if you want to just run again because you're
a completely disingenuous who lies to people on the internet
for money. If you want to do that again, that's cool, I guess.
This guy's very based. He's making up a lot of lies recently,
but this is a good one. Okay. It's totally, guys, it's totally
justified by the lawsuit according to Willy Mack, right? If you
read the lawsuit, it's incredibly obvious this did not read the
lawsuit. Okay? It's incredibly obvious he didn't read the lawsuit.
Here's here's all of the Al Husini references. This is the only
paragraph where Al Husseini is referenced in the context of this
lawsuit. Okay? In the text of the complaint, this is the only
place he's referenced. All right. In the wake of October 7th,
Hassan emerged as the modern incarnation of the Grand Muti, Hajamin
Al Husini. Al-Huseni from here on. Like Al Husini, Hassan became
a passionate advocate and highly charismatic leader of the Palestinian
cause. Oh, there's one similar similarity. Like Al Husseini,
Hassan used his massive platform to spread genocidal rhetoric
about anyone advocating for the right of self-determination in
their ancestral homeland, i.e. Zionists.
Okay, this is insane.
But I'll give you that. Okay, I'll give you that. Maybe you could
compare him to Al Husandi. Maybe. Maybe in these two ways that
they advocate for these things. The primary difference between
Hassan and Al Husseini is that Al Husseini worked with the Nazis
and advocated the annihilation of Oh, so he worked with Nazis.
They'll say the same thing about Hassan or will they use a different
thing about Hassan? Oh no, they they don't say that he worked
with Nazis at all. Okay, since the vast majority of in the United
States say caring about Israel is essential and important. This
is the conflation of the definition that we talked about. Willie
is not literate enough to be able to understand these definitions
or what Hassan thinks in any way. So he even if you give them
the genocide thing which is at a base level okay at a base level
that's already but even if you gave that to them they explicitly
say here well Hassan doesn't actually like we don't make that
claim that's the difference that Hassan doesn't do that he doesn't
work with Nazis it's also the conflation of Zionism and people
which is again another place people muddy the waters when they
don't really have like clean arguments to make that's fine even
if they support the Palestinian cause and vehemently condemn
the actions of the Israeli government this is the Zionist people
okay so this is the only two comparisons. So one, it's not it's
not like saying anything about Hassan other than we think Hassan
is anti-Semitic and then Hassan is related to denims. And then
the comparison to Al Husseini is basically that they spew genocidal
rhetoric about Jeans or something which is not a good it's basically
just calling somebody,
right? That's what they're doing. They're just calling